bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du Sénat pour suivre sur notre
antenne les explications de vote et puis
le vote final sur l'ensemble du projet
loi mariage pour tous au terme de 8
jours de débat intense passionné ici à
la haute assemblée et bien les sénateurs
vont donc voter finalement en fin
matinée sur ce projet de loi nous sommes
avec le rapporteur socialiste de ce
texte ici au Saat Jean-Pierre Michel
bonjour bonour pas trop fatigué non ça
va j'ai bien récupéré je dors très bien
donc ça va très bien voilà donc 8 jours
de débat passionné
intense oui mais c'était normal je crois
on s'attendait bien à une semaine de
débat peut-être à certains moment le
débat il était un peu ralenti un peu
répétitif mais il faut dire que le débat
toujours n'a jamais pas
enfin les propos en séance n'ont jamais
dépassé ce qui était convenu ce qui est
convenu voilà on n pasoc on n pas
assister à trop provocation donc tout ça
s'est déroulé plutôt bien je crois voilà
le rapporteur a fait connaître ses
arguments et finalement je suis assez
heureux que le texte qui sera voté tout
à l'heure soit conforme en tout point à
ce que voulait la commission des lois
c'est-à-dire que tous les amendements
ont été votés les amendements qui
devaient être rejetés l'ont été même si
il venait de parlementaire de la
majorité voulant ajouter la PMA ou
parler de la GPA et cetera donc tout
ceci a été rejeté car et renvoyé au
texte prochain sur sur la famille
jeanpen Michel vous qui êtes un fervant
partisan de ce mariage ouvert au
couplees homosexuel quel est votre état
d'esprit ce matin est-ce qu'il y a
l'émotion avant ce vote final du Sénat
ben l'émotion elle vient surtout du fait
que c'est pour moi la suite d'un combat
qui dure depuis le PACT on pourrait dire
et même un peu avant déjà rapporteur et
même un peu avant euh au moment du PCT
j'avais déjà dit que l'histoire ne
s'arrêterait pas là et aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il faut dire aussi que
l'histoire ne s'arrêtera pas là euh ça
provoque un certain nombre de crainte de
réticence c'est sûrement pas pour tout
de suite entre le Pax et le mariage pass
que s'arrêtera pas là vous pensez
justement à la PMA la GPA
différentes aux autres façons d'avoir
des enfants que la façon biologique ces
faç ces manières existent je ne porte
aucun jugement de valeur je dis
simplement que ça existe que la science
le permet que ça se pratique à
l'extérieur de façon cachée dans des
conditions quelquefois euh sanitaire ou
autrees absolument détestable et que
donc il faut bien que le législateur un
jour euh en prenne conscience et et
l'encadre voilà et le permettre et
l'encadre voilà cette évolution
sociétale vous le dites euh est en
marche avec une pierre de plus rajoutée
ce matin au Sénat mais même si le le
projet de loi ne va pas être adopté
définitivement il y aura une seconde
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat al il va y avoir une seconde
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale quand je
n'en sais rien moi je souhaite le plus
rapidement possible vous n'avez pas eu
de précision de la part à la fois de de
matigon ou relation par je pense que le
le ministre vidalis qui est venu hier je
crois ici euh attendait de savoir
comment ça allait se passer parce que
hier dans l'après-midi encore on ne
savait pas très bien euh si ça allait
être voté hier soir ou ce matin voà euh
alors l'Assemblée nationale je ne sais
pas ce qu'elle fera peut-être
sera-t-elle tentée de voter le texte
conforme c'est ce que je souhaite
également sans vouloir forcer la main au
députés Tex conforme par rapport à la
ver pour bien pour bien que les
téléspectateursion du Sénat d'accord ça
ça vous semble possible cetteion ça me
semble possible parce que la version qui
c'est un souit du gouvernement aussi ah
ça je n'en sais rien il faut lu demander
en tout cas la version qui so qui sort
du Sénat elle a été modifiée par rapport
à celle de l'Assemblée elle a été
enrichie elle a été peut-être mieux
écrite peut-être mieux calé
juridiquement mais rien de ce qui a été
voté ici n'est incompatible finalement
avec les débats qui sont passés à
l'Assemblée nationale donc je pense que
l'assemblée pourrait voter le texte son
forme est-ce que vous sentez que c'est
une volonté de la part des députés
notamment de votre homologue de
l'Assemblée le rapporteur à l'Assemblée
nationale al le rapporteur aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas quel est son état
d'esprit dans dans l'état actuel du
texte en tout cas dès le départ on
s'était rencontré pour essayer de
travailler un peu ensemble si j'ose dire
et pour faire en sorte que la version
qui serait adoptée ici au Sénat soit
compatible avec le B des députés à
l'Assemblée nationale mais tout ça est
soumis bien entendu au vote des députés
alors à la façon dont ils vont avoir
d'appréander le texte et si l'Assemblée
nationale vote la version du Sénat ça
simplifierait la procédure ça
accélérerait un peu l'adoption
définitive du T ça accélère parce que
tout le monde sait que le calendrier de
cette fin de printemps et début d'été
très chargé donc ça évitera au Sénat de
de revoir le texte une autre fois ça
permettra de saisir certainement le
Conseil constitutionnel plus rapidement
celui-ci a un mois je c oui puisque
l'opposition a annoncé effectivement qui
saisirit le Conseil constitutionnel sur
donc ça accélère la promulgation d'un
texte Jean-Pierre Michel vous souhaitez
toujours que le texte soit promulgué
voté définitivement pour la Guay Pride
de juin c'est ce que vous nous aviez dit
il y a un mois bien je pense que ça
serait bien que le jour de la Guay Pride
enfin le gouvernement se soutenu dans la
rue parce que pour l'instant le
gouvernement n'est pas tellement soutenu
dans la rue voilà donc vous regrettez
que les partisans du mariage pour tous
les couples ne soient pas plus
manifestés mais je crois que c'est c'est
normal si vous voulez les gens qui sont
partis dis an de quelque chose ils
savent que ça va se faire parce que
normalement bon ça faire et donc ils
nont pas ils n'ont pas intérêt ils sont
pas poussés à sortir dans la rue ils y
sont sortis une fois hier avantier il y
a eu quelques manifestations de de peu
d'importance il faut bien le dire en
nombre mais il y a eu des manifestations
quand même tous les jours ici autour du
Sénat par contre ceux qui sont opposés
contre le texte et ben ils sont là pour
faire pression et et pour voilà en
sachant très bien d'ailleurs que le
texte sera voté parce qu'ils le savent
oui et puis il y a la grande
manifestation attendu encore pour le 26
mai puis puis qu'il y a une date qui a
été euh oui elle sera peut-être un peu
trop tardive on n sait rien dernière
question Jean-Pierre Michel vous êtes
confiant sur le vote tout à l'heure ici
au Sénat vous pensez que le texte va
passer sans problème major je pense que
le texte va passer sans problème les
différents votes publics qui ont eu lieu
sur les motions sur les articles et
cetera ont donné une majorité assez
confortable par rapport à la majorité de
gauche puisqu'on sait qu' certain nombre
de sénateurs de l'opposition sénatoriale
UMP ou centriste votreont le texte
d'autres s'abstiennent ou ne prennent
pas part au vote ce qui change un peu
l'équation entre les pour et les contes
donc je pense qu'il y aura une majorité
de pour oui elle va pas être
extraordinairement large parce que la
majorité au Sénat n'est pas
extraordinairement large mais elle
existera merci Jean-Pierre Muel je vais
vous laisser rejoindre l'hémicycle du
Sénat où se déroulent les explications
de vote avant le le vote définitif en
fin de matinée on a déjà pu entendre ce
matin l'émotion d'Esther ben Bassa la
sénatrice écologiste qui a beaucoup
porté ce texte on a pu entendre
également les voix de l'opposition
François oketo le président du groupe
centriste ici au Sénat également Patrice
Géard qui était à la pointe du combat au
nom de l'UMP en ce moment c'est Rober ru
l'ancien secrétaire national du Parti
communiste sénateur aujourd'hui qui
s'exprime donc on rejoint l'émicycle
pour suivre cette séance en direct on
reviendra également ici avec de nombreux
invités pour commenter ses explications
de vote et puis pour commenter tout à
l'heure bien sûr le vote général autour
du projet loi et puis nous avons
toujours Delphine girérard qui se trouve
dans la tribune de presse au-dessus de
l'hémicycle bonjour Delphine bonjour
pine voilà quelle est l'ambiance ce
matin dans l'hémicycle alors c'est très
calme les orateurs prennent tour à tour
la parole pour les explications de vote
on ne sait pas combien d'orateurs sont
inscrits environ une trentaine le
président du Sénat n'a pas souhaité et
bien donner ce qu'on appelle le
dérouleur c'est-à-dire la liste des noms
des personnes des sénateurs qui vont
prendre la parole pour expliquer leur
vote ce matin en tous les cas si vous le
souhaitez berin ce qu'on peut dire
dirait bien c'est que la version qui va
sortir du Sénat si elle est votée en fin
de matinée est pas tout pas énormément
différente par rapport à la version ici
de l'Assemblée nationale comme vient de
vous le dire à l'instant Jean-Pierre
Michel il y a eu seulement une dizaine
d'amendements de la commission des lois
qui ont été voté elle porte surtout et
bien sur la consécration dans le Code
civil et bien de l'égalité de traitement
entre épou du même sexe le gouvernement
a fait adopter un amendement qui va
permettre justement et bien
de garantir par ordonnance la conformité
de cet égal traitement entre époux
conformité à la loi alors on va tout de
suite retourner dans l'hémicycle pour
suivre cette séance bonne matinée à
tous dignité des citoyens soit de
qu'elle soit demain renforcé que la
grande majorité des membres du groupe
RDSE votera ce texte merci la parole à
Madame Corine
bouchou monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues avec le vote de cette
loi les gay et les lesbiennes ou ceux et
celles qui ne se nomment pas comme tel
mais un homme qui aime un homme une
femme qui aime une femme pourront
choisir de vivre seul de vivre en union
libre de vivre paxé ou de se marier ou
de ne pas se marier de fond des familles
ou de ne pas faire famille d'élever des
enfants d'avoir des enfants ou de ne pas
le faire avec des droits et des devoir
c'est une loi de liberté qui n'enlève
rien à personne c'est une loi d'égalité
puissions-nous mal la virulence à
certains moments du débat malgré ce
qu'on a pu regretter à l'extérieur en
faire une loi de
fraternité merci la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Pierre
afffarin monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
venons de vivre un débat intéressant
pour nous et évidemment profondément
décevant je note pour commencer deux
petites satisfactions d'abord que après
la mise au point que nous avons faite
sur le dérapage de Monsieur Laurent il
n'y a plus dans cette assemblée
d'attaque et d'accusation sur
l'homophobie c'était quelque chose pour
nous d'inacceptable nous serions pas
restés à ces débats si les choses
avaient continué comme ça je remercie
tous les collègues du respect réciproque
que nous avons pu sur ces sujets
développer et parmi les les
satisfactions un débat très symbolique
et qui au fond résume assez bien ce
débat ça a été le choc des talents
latinistes entre Jean-Jacques yest et
Jean-Pierre suur la bataille du
nominatif contre l'accusatif et au fond
ça c'est un point très important et
finalement ça résume assez bien ça le
camp du nominatif le camp du nom le camp
du sujet le camp de l'accusatif le camp
de l'objet et de l'accusation c'est une
boutadee mais c'était simplement une
réponse à une joute dans que vous aviez
l'un et l'autre développé je veux
poursuivre en disant comme je l'ai déjà
dit qu'il y a là dans ce texte d'abord
une faute politique une double faute
politique le le premier le premier c'est
au fond première faute majeure c'est
qu'alors que le pays est sous un choc
social majeur que le chômage depuis 22
mois augmente et qu'il va continuer à
augmenter puisque les actions lourdes
qui devraient engager ne sont pas
engagées que cette souffrance sociale
est la première des souffrances de la
société on donne pas le sentiment que
c'est la priorité du législatif et de
l'exécutif nous sommes en plus dans une
crise morale qui est une crise majeure
qui attaque toutes les institutions qui
nous attaquent les uns et les autres
dans ce que nous avons de plus cher
notre éthique et au fond nous donnons le
sentiment d'apporter des réponses à côté
des préoccupations des Français je crois
que cette faute là elle est lourde elle
nous sera reprochée elle vous sera
profondément reprochée vous ajoutez une
rupture sociétale à une crise sociale et
un choc moral je regrette et c'est la
deuxième faute qu'on soit possé à côté
de véritables avancées consensuelles
dans notre pays notre histoire nous l'a
montré et j'avais pris l'exemple du
voile sur l'école notre histoire nous a
montré que quand nous sommes capables
d'avoir des consensus nous sommes
respectés dans la société mais ne croyez
pas que le vote de la loi effacera la
rupture que vous avez créé car cette
rupture ces milliers et milliers
centaines de milliers de gens qui ne
comprennent pas qui descendent dans la
rue pour dire le incompréhension du
sujet ces gens-là vont rester sur leur
position et ce qui était au départ un
choc de conscience devient un choc de
conviction et crée dans la société dé
blocages que le vote de la loi
n'effacera pas on aurait pu avancer sur
les couples homosexuels ensemble puisque
nous voulons tous non pas seulement par
compassion disait madame es Bassa tout à
l'heure mais surtout et avant tout par
respect la compassion d'accord mais
au-delà de la compassion il y a ce qui
est fondamental pour faire la loi le
respect et c'est ce respect- là qui nous
aurait pu permettre d'avancer ensemble
sur les couples homosexuels c'est ce
respect là qui aurait pu nous aider à
avancer ensemble notamment sur une
nouvelle pensée de l'adoption je vous
l'ai dit mais quand nous avons créé
l'agence nationale pour l'adoption on a
bien vu au fond que nous étions dans une
situation d'échec de l'adoption en
France on a voulu repenser une politique
et je dois l'avouer je dois le dire
cette politique n'est pas suffisante car
les échecs n'ont pas été surmontés
l'adoption reste un échec dans notre
pays vous avez ajouté des complexités
sans régler aucun des problèmes de notre
société je voudrais vous dire qu'il y a
là pour moi vraiment une occasion ratée
puisqu'il y avait de la bonne volonté on
n'a pas eu le débat vous avez pas choisi
une méthode politique de rassemblement
qui aurait pu faire en sorte sur ces
sujets majeurs de conscience on est une
approche rassemblée mon dernier mot est
pour exprimer un regret sur une
dimension de notre débat qui a assez peu
exister mais que je veux mettre dans ce
débat c'est la dimension spirituelle du
sujet je crois ça a été dit il y a eu
quelques opposition sur est-ce que
l'enfant est reçu est-ce que l'enfant
est désiré mais je crois qu'il est les
deux René Char avait cette belle phrase
aimer c'est vouloir que les choses
soient ce qu'elles sont c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a cette partie de volonté mais
il y a cette partie de réalité et cette
partie de réalité certains l'appellent
l'immanence certains l'appellent de
différents noms mais c'est la conscience
d'une réalité qui nous est quelque part
imposée parce que plus grande que nous
le lien entre le père la mère et
l'enfant est un lien de nature
historique qui nous dépasse sommes-nous
légitimes pour toucher à ce lien
d'humanité dans ce travail législatif
c'est ma grande Petion personnelle je ne
crois pas que nous soyons nécessairement
légitime pour toucher à ce lien qui est
un lien d'histoire qui est le lien de
vie qui touche à la fois à la naissance
à la création mais aussi au dépassement
je ne conteste pas votre ambition de
paradis social je ne je ne conteste pas
que vous voulez améliorer la vie sociale
que la sociale la dimension sociale la
société soit très importante je ne le
conteste pas mais je pense à Henri
Delubac qui disait il y a des paradis
sociaux qui sont quelquefois des enfer
spirituel merci
monsieurodini monsieur le président
madame la garde des seau madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mes chers collègues j'étais
présent dans l'hémicycle ce jeudi 4
avril quand vous êtes monté à la tribune
madame la garde des saau pour présenter
ce projet de loi relatif au mariage pour
couple de personnes de même sexe depuis
j'ai peu quitté ma place vivant des
moments intenses de travail
parlementaire des tensions vives aussi
des rires quelquefois mais vivant
surtout des moments de fierté fierté de
participer à la construction d'un texte
soutenu par mon groupe avec cohérence
cohésion sans ambigué groupe animé d'une
formidable conviction de promouvoir
l'égalité des droits pour toutes et tous
quelle que soit l'orientation sexuelle
l'argument a été avancé que ses jours
aurait pu être plus utilement consacré à
l'examen de la situation économique de
notre pays mes chers collègues le temps
de la démocratie n'est jamais perdu
quand il est consacré à construire de
nouveaux espaces de liberté quand il met
fin à une discrimination vieille de deux
siècles quand il est guidé par l'idéal
de justice devant lestandards de
l'égalité je veux d'abord vous remercier
mesdames les ministres madame la garde
des saau madame la ministre déléguée à
la famille de votre engagement de votre
talent de votre capacité à argumenter et
répondre aux interrogations du respect
dont vous avez témoigné pendant toutes
ces heures aux membres de la haute
assemblée madame la garde des saau très
souvent vous nous AZ subjugué merci
aussi aux deux rapporteurs merci au
président de la commission des lois au
président de séance mes remerciements
encore à mes collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale qui au-delà de leur
détermination ont manifesté tant de
patience d'écoute et de
sérénité merci aussi collègues de
l'opposition de leur tolérance opp
positionition de la majorité ici dans
cet hémicycle nous oublions à cet
instant les répétitions les tent
de désinformation les amalgames les
confusions nous l'oublions parce que le
vote de la loi traduisant l'engagement
du président de la République d'ouvrir
le mariage et l'adoption à droit
constant au couple de même sexe est un
vote emblématique oui un vote qui
marquera l'histoire c'est bien le
mariage avec toute sa charge symbolique
et toutes ses règles d'ordre publ qui
s'ouvre au couple de même sexe dans les
mêmes conditions d'âge et de
consentement de la part de chacun des
conjoints avec les mêmes interdits les
mêmes prohibitions avec les mêmes
obligations d'assistance de fidélité de
respect avec les mêmes obligations pour
chaque conjoint vis-à-vis l'un de
l'autre les mêmes devoirs des enfants
vis-à-vis de leurs parents et des
parents vis-à-vis de leurs enfants c'est
selon les mêmes processus dans les mêmes
conditions que les couples hétérosexuels
que les couples hétérosexuels que les
couples homosexuels pourront adopter
l'agrément sera accordé selon les mêmes
règles par les conseils généraux
l'adoption prononcée dans les mêmes
conditions par le juge conformément à
l'article 353 du Code civil qui dispose
que l'adoption est prononcée si elle est
conforme au droit de l'enfant
aujourd'hui nous parachevons l'évolution
vers l'égalité d'une institution le
mariage civil auquel la Constitution de
1791 a donné naissance une évolution qui
a concerné d'abord les femmes comment
imaginez aujourd'hui qu'il y a 40 ans
les femmes avaient encore besoin de
l'autorisation de leurs époux pour
ouvrir un compte bancaire une évolution
qui reconnaît aussi progressivement les
droits des enfants et ce n'est qu'en
1972 que le législateur sa établir une
différence entre les enfants légitimes
et les enfants naturels une évolution
qui rend justice aux personnes
homosexuelle l'homosexualité ne doit pas
seulement être dépouillée de ses
qualifications d'infraction de fléau de
maladie ou de péchés ce sont des droits
et devoirs équivalents à ceux de
l'étérosexualité qui doivent lui être
confié autrefois institution de
propriété de possession d'exclusion le
mariage devient une institution
universelle des droits nouveaux sont
accordés aucun n'est enlevé à ceux qui
les possèdent déjà chacun a le droit de
s'unir avec la personne qu'il aime de
protéger son conjoint de fond une
famille avec des enfants reconnus et
protégés chers collègues dans cette
évolution la France n'est pas seule elle
rejoint les Pays-Bas la Belgique
l'Espagne le Canada l'Afrique du Sud la
Norvège la Suède le Portugal l'Islande
l'Argentine mais aussi le RoyaumeUni et
l'Uruguay si des états des nations-
Unies considèrent encore aujourd'hui que
l'homosexualité est un crime aucun de
ces pays n'a connu le chaos et la guerre
civile le groupe socialiste votera le
texte du projet de loi et permettez-moi
de conclure avec Montesquieu une chose
n'est pas juste parce qu'elle est loi
mais elle doit être loi parce qu'elle
est j merci la parole à madame Isabelle
Pasquet merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues avec le vote de cette loi nous
pouvons nous fa nous féliciter mes chers
collègues qu'à côté du droit du mariage
s'érigera enfin un véritable droit au
mariage dont chacune et chacun pourra se
prévaloir les mesures que nous avons
voté durant ces longs jours de débat ne
feront que traduire les évolutions de
notre société le législateur a
simplement pris acte de ces évolutions
et dans l'intérêt général il lui revient
aujourd'hui de voter cette loi afin que
l'ensemble des citoyens bénéficie des
mêmes protections des mêmes droits des
mêmes obligations l'intérêt de l'enfant
a beaucoup été invoqué durant ce long
des débat la question de l'égalité n'a
pas occulté celle de l'homoparentalité
loin de là et je dirais même que les
principales oppositions se sont
cristallisé sur ce point essentiel celui
du bien-être de nos enfants d'un côté
c'est rassurant même si au final nous ne
n'apportons pas les mêmes réponses en
fonction du côté de l'hémicycle où nous
nous trouvons pour moi ouvrir un droit
qui combat les discriminations et
protecteur nous avons entendu les
inquiétudes de chacune et chacun mais
nous sommes convaincus que cette loi
n'est que bien fait pour ses bien pour
ses enfants les arguments consistants à
dire que la loi détruira la famille ne
sont que fantasmés la famille en sortira
au contraire renforcé les arguments
invvoquant l'hypothétique risque
physiologique ou psychologique encouru
par un enfant élevé par un couple
homosexuel ne sont pas plus pertinents
en effet mes chers collègues n'oublions
pas que notre motivation première est de
répondre à la détresse d'enfants nés ou
qui naîtront dans ses familles leur
protection aujourd'hui est fragilisé par
le fait que l'un des deux parents n'a
aucun lien juridique avec l'enfant qui
l'élève avec son conjoint leur intérêt
commande qu'il puisse enfin bénéficier
comme les autres de la protection de la
loi
merci la parole à Vincent DEAE
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers
collègues à l'issue de ce débat moi il y
a plusieurs choses qui m'ont
marqué la première chose qui qui m'a
marqué c'est le dialogue de Sour auquel
nous avons assisté ici au Sénat dialogue
de Sour qui je pense restera dans les
anales et servira sans doute au futur
instituts d'études politiques pour
montrer un un cas de de figure qui n'est
pas à suivre bien bien entendu le
deuxième point c'est la façon dont le
gouvernement et la majorité ont minimisé
caricaturé et plus grave encore ignorer
l'émotion et les convictions exprimées
par des centaines de milliers de
Français au cours de de cette période
durant laquelle nous avons
débattu le troisième point c'est que à
une crise politique majeure que nous
vivons actuellement une crise économique
et sociale nous rajoutons une crise
sociétale et ça je pense que c'est pas
une bonne chose et le dernier point
c'est que
le gouvernement devrait rassembler et
tous les élus doivent rassembler quand
on est élu local on cherche à rassembler
sur le plan local je pense qu'au niveau
national on aurait dû avoir cet esprit
de rassemblement et alors là on l'a pas
du tout senti on a senti face à nous un
mur un mur de conviction sans doute mais
un mur vraiment
inébranlable alors sur le fond sur le
fond du sujet je pense que il y a la
quasi unanimité pour dire que nous
reconnaissons aux homosexuels le droit
de vivre en couple nous reconnaissons
que ils ont subi des discrimination
pendant des années que nous sommes
contre ces
discriminations donc sur une partie du
texte et la reconnaissance de leur
droits sociaux et fiscaux nous sommes
tout à fait d'accord et je pense qu'on
aurait pu avoir un vote unanime sur le
sujet en revanche en revanche pourquoi
céder à la frange la plus extrême avec
le collectif LGBT
des homosexuels pourquoi pourquoi créer
un droit à l'enfant qui n'existait
absolument pas jusqu'à présent pourquoi
donner la primauté de ce droit à
l'enfant par rapport au droits de
l'enfant pourquoi créer un nouveau type
d'enfant parce que type d'enfant c'est
pas que il y a pas d'enfants aujourd'hui
qui vivent avec deux hommes ou deux
femmes la nouveauté ça va être que avec
la loi il va y avoir des enfants qui
deain auront deux papas ou deux mamans
et en l'occurrence sur certains banc on
entend souvent le principe de précaution
utilisé à tort et à travers je ne vois
pas pourquoi pour l'être humain on
nutiliserait pas ce principe de
précaution et pour les enfants qui st à
naître pourquoi on aurait on l'aurait
pas mis en avant donc il y a il y a vous
vous vous le sentez bien mes chers
collègues je pense de de ma part une
volonté constructive j'étais venu dans
ce débat avec cette volonté constructive
je me suis aperçu que elle n'était que
d'un bord alors chez nous à droite et au
centre il y a eu des des expressions
d'opinion différentes à gauche on a
entendu ou on a peu entendu en tout cas
mais on a entendu aucune différence
alors qu'on sait bien que dans la
population le clivage n'est pas à
gauche- droite le clivage va à
l'intérieur de chaque camp et à gauche
je l'ai dit lors de certaines
interventions on a des personnes qui ont
osé s'exprimer qui ont osé s'exprimer en
dehors des hémicycles et euh bon il y a
Elisabeth kigou que j'ai j'ai cité
d'ailleurs ceux qui voudront se reporter
à son texte sur le pax il y a 15 ans qui
est très instructif et son virage à 180°
sur un tel sujet à mon avis décère la
parole politique mais il y a aussi
Lionel Jospin ancien Premier ministre
son épouse et aussi aussi beaucoup
beaucoup d'élus beaucoup d'élus de
gauche qui se sont exprimés en dehors de
l'hémicycle et qui montrent qu'à gauche
aussi il y a des
courageux donc j'aurais aimé entendre
les mêmes courageux ici j'ai
l'impression qu'on les a bayonné
et ça donne l'impression d'un débat
comme je disais tout à l'heure un
dialogue de Sour et un débat qui n'a
finalement pas eu lieu et c'est fort
dommage donc pour toutes ces raisons mes
chers collègues à la fois l'attitude du
gouvernement à la fois la création d'un
droit à l'enfant et d'un nouveau type
d'enfant et dernier point l'ouverture
sur lequel vous nous avez pas du tout
rassuré madame la ministre l'ouverture
vers la PMA et la GPA et demain sans
doute la marchandisation des enfants
pour pour tous ces points là je voterai
comme la quasi unanimité du groupe udi
contre ce texte merci la parole à
Monsieur Jean-Vincent
placer monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres monsieur le Président de
la Commission madamees et monsieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues au terme
de ce débat je veux me réjouir de la
passion qui a embrasé nos rangs majorité
opposition nous n'avons pas ménagé nos
forces mais nous nous sommes battus pied
à pied car nous avions malgré tout un
point commun dans cette discussion la
conscience que ce texte était tout sauf
anodin ces derniers jours beaucoup
d'arguments juridiques divers ont été
égrainés défendu développer je vous
propose pour ces explications de vote de
les oublier oublions en effet tout cela
oublions la technique les arcanes du
droit et prenons une ultime fois le
sujet au cœur le sujet du mariage
j'entends parmi vous une crainte
profonde c'estelle de voir que l'on
touche à quelque chose de sacré le
mariage et c'est à vous que je voudrais
m'adresser oui le mariage est sacré bien
sûr qu'il est sacré et je ne parle pas
ici de religion qui parle d'ailleurs ici
de religion nous sommes Laï et
républicain nous parlons de mariage
civil et je vous le dis ce mariage civil
pour moi est sacré dans nos cœurs
l'essence du mariage c'est le couple et
le ciment de ce couple c'est l'amour
l'amour un mot que l'on n pas assez
entendu ces derniers temps c'est en cela
que ce mariage est sacré dans nos cœurs
chers amis moi je vous propose de lever
votre bulletin de votes chers collègues
affichez fièrement cette couleur puisque
nous en avons parlé hier et dites que
oui vous acceptez qu'il s'aime et
qu'elle s'aime que oui en France être
homosexuel c'est être et vivre comme
tout le monde que oui nous sommes du
même monde que nous partageons les mêmes
envies dans la vie être heureux être
compris pouvoir dire oui devant un mère
devant sa famille devant ses amis devant
tous ses proches fonder une famille que
oui il pourra dire à tous c'est lui que
j'ai soisi que oui elle pourra dire à
tous et toutes c'est elle que j'ai
choisi cette loi semble
heurter certaines sensibilités c'est
pourtant c'est moments rares qu on se
trouve face à soi-même avec le pouvoir
de participer en toute liberté à une
révolution majeure de notre société le
pouvoir de corriger une règle de notre
société en se disant que l'on devait
être bien aveugle pour ne pas avoir pris
cette décision plusutôt notre société
doit se débarrasser de ces peaux mortes
préserver et cultiver les belles choses
qui a construit au fil du temps mais
tourner le dos à l'inégalité et avancer
face à l'égalité je suis hétérosexuel
comme la plupart d'entre vous d'entre
nous que l'on vienne ici vous dire que
vous n'avez pas le droit d'époser celle
que vous aimez et de quel droit
répondrez-vous cela vous semble absurde
mais c'est bien de cela dont on parle
c'est bien de cela que certains
ressentent sentez là le vent tout
simplement de histoire ça a été dit dans
nombre de pays c'est déjà fait qui
souffle dans ses rangs autour de nous
c'est pour cela que je me suis engagé en
politique et je n'ai plus de mot pour
vous dire la fierté qui est la mienne la
fierté qui est la mienne d'être ceux et
celles qui auront dans l'histoire de
notre pays soutenu ce noble combat
aujourd'hui nous avons débattu et
longuement débattu personne n'aura pu se
démontrer qu'il n'y avait pas une
injustice patente et cette injustice
nous devons l'enterrer maintenant on
nous regarde je ne parle pas de ceux qui
sont en tribune et que je salue où je
vois nombre de visages amis dans la rue
ou devant la télé je parle des enfants
des petits enfants de la France de
demain qui seront d'ailleurs issu de
coupe hétérosexuel ou de couple
homosexuel ceux-là qui regarderont ce
jour avec le respect l'émotion que l'on
ressent pour les mots qui marquent les
grandes avancées sociales pour les jours
historiques mes chers collègues je suis
sénateur comme vous et j'ai peut-être
une
spécificité c'est que à la différence de
beaucoup qui parlent de l'adoption moi
je sais ce que je sais ce que ce que que
c'est j'ai été orphelin j'ai eu la
chance extraordinaire d'être adopté par
une famille française qui avait déjà des
enfants naturel trois frères et une sœur
que j'ai eu la chance de côtoyer pendant
ma jeunesse il y avait pas un désir
d'enfant supplémentaire il y avait de
mes parents une envie de partager de
donner de l'amour et de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un autre modèle familial que
vous raconter de la famille de papamaman
et du droit du sang quelque part et moi
je vous le dis je souhaite que vous res
tier ces couples homosexuels qui vont
adopter dans les mois à venir qui ont
envie non pas de se faire plaisir mais
de concrétiser leur amour dans des
valeurs qu'ils veulent transmettre dans
un amour qu'il veulent partager dans des
sujets qui seront ceux de faire en sorte
que notre société elle se perpétue avec
ces valeurs là qui sont partagées et
donc franchement je vous le dis vous
avez été extrêmement caricaturaux dans
les notions d'adoption que je crois vous
ne maîtrisez pas beaucoup et vraiment je
vous le dis du fond du cœur respectecter
ces familles c'est tout ce que je vous
demande pour la fin de ce débat respecte
ces familles qui verront le jour et ces
enfants qui verront le jour dans
quelques mois et dans quelques années
alors aujourd'hui je vote pour que tous
les couples puissent s'unir devant la
loi qu'importe leur religion leur
couleur de peau leur conditions sociales
le orientation sexuelle je vote pour le
mariage pour toutes et pour tous Je
vouscie merci la parole à Bruno
rotaillot
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues je siège
dans cette assemblée depuis plusieurs
années et j'ai eu l'occasion de voir
passer de nombreux textes mais jamais je
n'ai senti le poids d'une telle
responsabilité et je crois que cette
responsabilité d'ailleurs quel que soit
le banc le siège que nous occupions
devrait nous amener à nous poser trois
questions la première c'est est-ce que
nous la prendrons cette responsabilité
pour changer notre pacte social par la
voix d'une loi ordinaire ce que vous
proposez c'est le chemin d'un changement
radical profond pour le mariage mais
aussi pour l'affiliation le mariage
c'est une évidence le mariage désormais
ne sera plus cette institution qui a été
inventée par les sociétés partout autour
de la planète pour donner un cadre
protecteur au plus faible au plus
vulnérables aux fmes aux enfants pour
donner aussi un cadre stable pour que le
renouvellement génération puisse se
faire pour que la transmission des
patrimoines matériel immatériel et
spirituel comme le disait si bien
Jean-Pierre affarin à l'instant puisse
passer de génération en
génération l'impact sur le mariage c'est
évident mais aussi l'impact sur la
filiation une filiation qui depuis des
siècles et même au-delà était fondée sur
une réalité une réalité biologique et
symbolique lorsqu'il s'agissait de
l'adoption une filiation qui désormais
sera fondée sur une intention sur une
volonté avec toute la fragilité qu'une
intention ou une volonté peuvent porter
et bien vous avez voulu chers collègues
ce texte au nom de l'égalité mais cette
égalité pour les adultes va se traduire
par des injustice pour les enfants pour
ceux qui n'auront pas accès à leurs
origines pour ceux qui ne connaîtront ni
papa ni maman cette double figure ce
double visage de notre humanité bien sûr
comme vous nous avons à cœur de soulager
toutes les souffrances mais ça ne doit
pas être au prix d'en susciter d'en
créer de nouvelles les enfants justement
c'est la deuxième question ils devrait
être ils ont été d'ailleurs au cœur de
nos débats au cœur de nos débats mais
pourtant cela risque d'être les grands
oubliés les grands perdants de cette
réforme parce que derrière ce slogan le
mariage pour tous il y avait le droit à
l'enfant pour tous le droit à l'adoption
pour tous mais méfions-nous que ce droit
à l'adoption pour tous se transforme au
final en adoption pour personne parce
que parce que cette décision que nous
nous apprêtons à prendre risque de tarir
euh les enfants d'adoption dans les pays
d'origine qui vont considérer c'est déjà
le cas pour des grands pays de l'Est que
la France ne tient pas suffisamment
compte de l'intérêt supérieur des
enfants c'est une évidence et puis nous
l'avons dit nous l'avons répété ce texte
est une tromperie parce que c'est un
cheval de troit parce que c'est un
engrenage aujourd'hui le mariage
l'adoption aujourd'hui aussi la PMA nous
l'avons montré c'est clair c'est une loi
qui va régulariser la fraude des
situations de fraude peut-on l'accepter
et demain bien sûr une tromperie parce
que l'engrenage nous amènera au bout de
ce texte au bout de ce texte à la GPA
bien sûr vous vous avez voulu ce texte
aussi au nom du progrès au nom aussi de
la modernité mais quelle est cette
modernité quand le marché déjà toque à
notreoporte ici en France rue Cambon
dans un hôtel où des grands laboratoires
américains font leurs proposition
sordide pour la fabrique d'enfants
parfait est-ce cela le progrès est-ce
cela la modernité et la troisième
question est-ce que cette réforme relève
des représentants du peuple ou du peuple
lui-même nous pensons qu'elle relève du
peuple bien sûr parce qu'on ne change
pas madame la garde des saau une
civilisation par la loi ordinaire le
président de la République lorsque il
avait indiqué qu'il s'agissait d'un
droit à la liberté de conscience avait
raison ça n'est pas un texte comme les
autres et le peuple nous le demande et
vous le voyez d'ailleurs il est en train
de basculer massivement il bascule
contre ce texte le peuple voudrait et
c'est bien normal non pas pour des
droits àis mais s'exprimer pour la
conviction pour sa conviction le
référendum c'était une exigence c'était
aussi la voix de l'apaisement et bien
non je ne prendrai pas cette
responsabilité de voter ce texte je vous
la laisse je vous la laisse mais vous
aurez à l'assumer pour les nouvelles
génération certains d'entre nous ont
parlé d'histoire de moments historiques
vous aurez à l'assumer devant l'histoire
mais surtout vous aurez à l'assumer
devant tous les Français merci la parole
à Madame Catherine
taska
pendant tout notre débat beaucoup
d'intervenants ont invoqué la nécessité
de respecter le sens des mot en
particulier celui du mot mariage cela
honore l'attachement de notre haute
assemblée à la langue française mais
franchement nous ne sommes pas à
l'Académie française nous n'avons pas
besoin de convoquer le petit Robert nous
devons faire notre travail de
législateur en nous attachant non
seulement aux mots mais aux faits au aux
réalités de la société aux attentes des
citoyens nous avons clairement entendu
les difficultés de vie que connaissent
les couples de même sexe et leurs
enfants ces difficultés vous n'avez pas
voulu les entendre dans ce ce côté si de
l'hémicycle lors de l'adoption du Pax
votre effort de rattrapage avec la
proposition d'un nouveau contrat d'union
civil ne trompe personne vu votre peu
d'empressement sur ce sujet pendant vos
10 années de gouvernement aujourd'hui
l'objectif de la loi est de donner à
tous sans discrimination une égale
liberté de choix nos concitoyens
disposent d'un éventail de possibilités
pour organiser leur vie commune union
libre concubinage Pax mariage au nom de
quoi les couples de même sexe
n'auraient-ils pas accès à l'ensemble de
ces possibilités on parle beaucoup de
reconnaître leur amour mais ce n'est pas
le sujet essentiel pour le législateur
le vrai sujet pour ses couples et leurs
enfants c'est que le mariage organise un
engagement durable et juridiquement
sécurisé où chaque partenaire trouve son
juste droit dans l'Union comme en cas de
séparation ou de deuil dans une société
du changement de la précarité et il faut
bien le dire d'un individualisme
ravageur pourquoi refuser le libre choix
du mariage au couples de même sexe qui
souhaiteraient légitimement fixer leur
union rien ne le justifie et me tournant
vers ceux qui n'ont pas fait le même
choix que nous je veux surtout dire que
trop d' dé faaut sont enfermé notre
débat dans un une ronde sans fin même si
nous n'espérons pas nous convaincre les
uns les autres au moins devons-nous nous
écouter le procès en mensonge que vous
intentez à ce texte est sans fondement
compte tenu de son périmètre clairement
délimité de même votre procès concernant
l'altérité que vous limitez à la
relation homme-femme et lui aussi sans
fondement prétendre que ce texte tend à
nier l'altérité comme vous le répétez
sans cesse est un contesens ou un
fantasme propre à impressionner
l'opinion nous n'avons jamais songé à
nier la différence biologique des sexes
et soyez sûr que les enfants élevés par
une famille homoparentale eux ne
confondront pas et n'imagineront pas un
instant être né de deux hommes ou de
deux femmes ils ont les yeux ouverts
faites-leur donc confiance ce sont des
situations qu'on ne peut regarder
abstraitement je songe à tous ces
parents d'élèves qui ne voyaient aucune
objection à l'expulsion des étrangers
sans papi et qui changeaient
radicalement de point de vue le jour où
cela frappait un enfant dans la même
école dans la même classe que leur
propre enfant même parmi les plus
farouches opposant au mariage des
personnes de même sexe chacun peut se
trouver un jour devant la R réalité de
l'homosexualité d'un enfant d'un parent
d'un ami alors son regard changera
nécessairement et il pourra même se
réjouir que la loi leur est assurée
droit de citer enfin lorsque ce texte
sera adopté bien loin des
bouleversements annoncés ce sera pour
toutes les familles concernées une
nouvelle heureuse bien plus joyeuse que
toutes les annonces catastrophistes que
nous avons entendu tout au long du débat
c'est à elle que nous penserons en
votant ce texte qui ne fait ni plus ni
moins que mettre fin à une
discrimination d'un autre âge et tout
simplement conforter un ordre
républicain qui doit nécessairement
s'adresser à tous les citoyens sans
aucune
discrimination même si certains ne l'ont
toujours pas
admis merci la parole à madame la
Présidente Ian
Assassi
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues en votant
en faveur de ce texte nous prendrons
aujourd'hui le chemin d'une société plus
égalitaire plus juste plus soucieuse du
bien-être des individus ce faisant nous
allons commettre un acte de grande
portée qui réaffirmera l'image de notre
pays celle de la patrie des droits de
l'homme qui reconnaissonsle sont
aujourd'hui bien mis à mal nous allons
découvrir l'égalit
ce qui n'est pas un acte mineur car ce
n'est pas simplement un progrès pour les
couples homosexuels c'est un progrès
pour tous les couples qui conçoivent le
mariage comme un espace d'amour un
espace de liberté beaucoup d'arguments
ont été développés sur tous les bans de
notre assemblée certains plus vivs que
les autres mais Infiné ils ont démontré
que sur le fond ce sont bien deux
projets de société qui se sont affrontés
en tout état de cause je crois pouvoir
dire que tous les élus du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyens sont
fiers de rendre possible une nouvelle
liberté sans oublier que le
chemin a été semé d'en bûche et que si
nous en sommes là aujourd'hui c'est
grâce aussi aux luttes aux actions
d'association et de forces politiques
progressistes qui se sont batttu pendant
des années pour dire que le mariage pour
les couplle de personnes du même sexe
représenterait un enjeu d'égalité et de
justice sociale je tiens d'ailleurs ici
à les saluer et à leur rendre hommage
ainsi aujourd'hui notre assemblée va
contribuer à une avané humaine et nous
nous mettrons aussi dans les pas de
celles et ceux qui ont voté l'abolition
de la peine de mort avec la loi Badinter
ou qui ont voté celle autorisant l'IVG
de Madame veille oui notre vote
d'aujourd'hui va mettre fin une
discrimination qui s'appuie sur un ordre
la domination patriarcale et qui va
permettre qu'enfin le mariage ne se
réduise pas à un modèle familial unique
où amour et sexualité sont liés à la
procréation et à
laaffiliation nous en finirons ainsi
avec une certaine hypocrisie et ainsi
aussi mettre fin à des souffrances et à
des frustrations oui notre vote
d'aujourd'hui va en finir avec un modèle
qui serait certains de nos collègues de
l'opposition fondé sur la seule loi de
la nature niant ainsi le fait que les
droits acquis par les peuple et par les
femmes en particulier ont permis de
dépasser l'état nature oui chers
collègues notre vote d'aujourd'hui peut
contribuer à ce que des hommes des
femmes des enfants puissent enfin vivre
un vrai bonheur en toute liberté oui
chers collègues comme le disait saint
juste le bonheur est une idée neuve nous
nous pouvons aujourd'hui le démontrer
avec force et c'est donc avec une grande
fierté que les élus communistes
républicains et citoyens voteront pour
ce texte merci la parole à Madame
Chantal
Joan merci monsieur le Président mesame
les ministres mes chers collègues comme
vous le savez je voterai favorablement
ce texte même si ma position est
minoritaire au sein de mon groupe mais
que dans le cadre du groupe udi UC nous
sommes attachés à la liberté de vote et
d'expression des uns et des autres et
j'en suis très fière que nous puissions
effectivement nous exprimer très
librement sur ce sujet où les certitudes
non'ont certainement pas leur
place je vote parce que j'ai des
convictions libérales qui ne s'arrêtent
pas aux enjeux économiques et qui
touchent aussi les questions de société
et dans cette nouvelle liberté je ne
vois pas d'atteinte au principe
républicain qui justifierait donc une
intervention de l'État ou une limitation
de l'État quant à cette liberté certains
me diront qu'il y a l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant mais cet intérêt supérieur
n'est pas juridiquement défini
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai problème
d'ailleurs il y a pas de charte de
l'enfant on a fait une charte de
l'environnement il faudrait faire une
charte de l'enfant si nous considérons
que l'intérêt supérieur d'un enfant et
d'avoir un père et une mère biologique
nous allons vite tomber sur des écueils
quant à ce que nous disons aux mères
célibataires aux familles
monoparentales à l'interruption
volontaire de
grossesse par conséquent ça peut-être
potentiellement une voix assez
dangereuse ou délicate en tout cas dans
notre dans notre discours et
deuxièmement comme d'ailleurs je pense
la très très grande majorité de mes
collègues ici je pense que les familles
homot parental ont la même capacité à
assumer leur responsabilités de parents
et à élever des enfants dans le cadre
d'un projet parental et je parle bien
d'un projet parental parce que
aujourd'hui l'enfant est souvent le
fruit d'un projet parental ne serait-ce
que parce que le droit à la
contraception fait que l'enfant est le
fruit d'un projet parental dans la très
grande majorité des cas alors c'est vrai
ce texte de loi se heurte à deux écueils
et ne répond pas à deux questions
fondamentales la première est celle de
l'adoption et tout particulièrement de
l'adoption pliniiaère qui crée une
fiction et la question se pose à tous
aujourd'hui d lors que cette adoption
pliniiaire gomme les origines jusqu'où
devons-nous aller dans la fiction est-ce
que ce dispositif qui était justifié
pendant un temps l'est encore ça pour
moi c'est un vrai sujet nous n'y avons
pas répondu il faudra y répondre je suis
pas favorable à ce que les origines
soient gommées deuxièmement la
procréation médicalement
assistée jusqu'où devons-nous aller dans
la médicalisation on a ouvert la
procréation médicalement assisté au
principe du tiers d'honneur donc on a
déjà créé une brèche dans le principe
aujourd'hui jusqu'où faut-il aller c'est
aussi une question auquelle nous n'avons
pas répondu c'est dommage d'ailleurs que
ce débat a été pris à l'envers avant que
nous ayons eu les conclusions du Conseil
consultatif national d'éthique ça doit
être dans ce sens-là ou dans un autre
sens mais le principe le principe est le
même donc ces questions nous n'y avons
pas répondu et c'est dommage parce que
ça peut justifier beaucoup d'opposition
à ce texte d'ailleurs sur différents
même si elle s'exprime si elle s'exprime
plus ou moins donc une page avec ce vote
va se tourner une autre page s'ouvre
très honnêtement dans notre société
aujourd'hui le temps doit être à
l'apaisement à la
réconciliation et veillons à ce que tous
les discours que nous tenons que nous
soyons pour ou que nous soyons contre
nous essayons de les tenir comme s'il
s'agissait de nos propres enfants je
vous remercie merci merci la parole à
Nicolas
Alfonsi
chers collègues madame le ministre
monsieur le
Président je n'ai pas participé au
débat j'ai voté pour François
Hollande je n'ai pas voté la proposition
dans mon esprit je n'ai pas voté la
proposition
31 euh faudrait-il pour autant qu'une
forme de mandat impératif me conduise
aujourd'hui à voter le texte qui nous a
présenté la réponse est
non cet engagement lit François Hollande
et ne lit pas nécessairement tous ceux
qui ont pu voter pour lui car aurait-il
fallu que chaque électeur de François
Hollande vote l'ensemble des
propositions au demeurant serait-il él
dans ces conditions pour que l'on puisse
voter le cœur léger uNEX de cette
importance dans ces
conditions je le répète je ne suis lié
par aucun engagement et je considère que
je n'ai pas si je n'ai pas voté la
motion référendaire que j'aurais pu
voter compte tenu du fond c'est tout
simplement parce que je souhaitais que
le débat continue et je ne voulais pas
laisser le Sénat dans un état de
frustration comme cela a pu se produire
à l'occasion du vote du budget je n'ai
donc pas voté la motion référendaire
mais et je laisse libre le président de
la République de choisir les moyens de
ses choix parlementaires ou
référendaires il a choisi la voix
parlementaire au nom d'un principe de
réalité il a la majorité il est libre de
ses choix il choisit la la voix qui lui
permet de faire voter ce texte très bien
c'est ce principe de réalité par contre
dont il ne tient pas compte et il a sans
doute raison à l'occasion de la
proposition 56 puisque là la majorité
constitutionnelle n'existant pas il
renonce on devine le sentiment de
frustration et ceux qui n'auraient pas
voté pour François Hollande que pour
cette proposition là il a le principe de
réalité s'impose il aurait pu tenir
compte d'une autre réalité celle des
manifestants ceux de la cô ceux de
l'Ouest parisien et ceux de l'Est
parisien dans ce débat où on tient une
contababilité notariale de ceux qui
protestent pour et de ceux qui
protestent contre mais on oublie et
finalement je crois que je suis le seul
interprète dans l'assemblée de cela on
oublie tous ceux qui n'ont pas manifesté
et qui était pour François Hollande et
contre la proposition 31 tout à fait
voilà là voilà voilà le problème le
problème pour moi se pose dans ces terme
et comme je tiens exclusivement au
mandat représentatif je regrette de
m'étendre sur ce point qui me paraît
important on tient je tiens au mandat
représentatif encore une fois je veux
prendre ma liberté alors je ne je
n'évoquerai pas le fond vous vous êtes
épuisé nous nous sommes épuisés pendant
3 jours je dirais simplement que le
mariage j'ai déjà une institution malade
faudrait-il l'achever euh en prolongeant
en quelque sorte toutes ces libertés qui
sont prises je respecte toutes les
sensibilités mais j'ai toujours eu le
sentiment que si je ne participais pas à
ce vote il y aurait quelque chose de ma
part qui serait un manquement à mes
devoirs il y a eu des problèmes qui se
sont posés je nai pas participer au vote
mais ce sont des choses trop importantes
pour ne pas voter alors nous sommes en
diverg
sur ce point avec le groupe roberu on a
parlé de cette marche vers l'égalité
parfaite et roberu a même cité un auteur
que je connais bien qui dit que qui nous
enseigne que la démocratie c'est
toujours la marche vers toujours plus de
liberté bien je lui ai dit amicalement
que s'il avait poursuivi sa lecture
montesquie nous dit quelque part autant
le ciel est éloigné de la
terre autant le véritable esprit
d'égalité l'est-il de celui d'égalité
extrême et c'est cette règle qui a
toujours qui m'a toujours conduit dans
ma vie publique c'est ce phare qui a
toujours été le fondement de mon action
comprendre dans ces conditions que je
voterai contre le texte madame HL
lipz monsieur
président et voilà donc on va écouter
l'Inter tion à la place d'Hélène piiz au
sein du groupe écologiste on a raté tout
à l'heure l'intervention d'Esther
Benbassa qui a vraiment porté au sein de
ce groupe ce texte mariage pour tous
Esther bbassa qui était ce matin à 9h
très ému dans l'hémicycle du Sénat on la
réécoute permettez-moi pour cette
explication de vote de ne pas reprendre
ici les arguments déjà développés par
beaucoup en faveur de l'adoption de ce
projet de loi permettez-moi de ne pas
céder non plus en cet instant si
solennel aux séductions de la polémique
et de ne de ne pas répondre une iè fois
aux arguments du camp
adverse je souhaite seulement donner je
souhaite seulement donner à mon
intervention un peu de chair d'esprit un
peu de cette simple humanité qui a
parfois manqué à au débat ce qui est
normal et vous raconter une
histoire il y a 30 ans au début des
années
1980 donc alors professeur dans
l'enseignement secondaire j'ai rencontré
dans le fond d'archive où je préparais
ma thèse d'État un jeune doctorant
américain par le plus pur des hasards
nous travaillons sur des sujets connexes
exploite et exploition souvent les mêmes
sources il avait l'isance et le Brau de
ses étudiants des grandes universités de
la côte Est et je l'enviaise un peu bien
sûr à force de travailler côte à côte
nous finimmes par devenir
amis un soir d'hiver après une longue
après-midi passée en bibliothèque
sortant tous deux du métro châtelé voilà
qu'il me prend par la main et me fait
entrer presque de force dans le premier
bistro qu'il trouve pour me dire quelque
chose pour me dire qu'il est
gay et pour me dire sa peur panique que
cet aveu met brutalement fin à notre
déjà riche amitié je n'oublierai jamais
son émotion et aussi quelque chose qui
ressemblait chez lui à de la honte je
n'oublierai jamais l'expression sombre
anxieuse de son
visage je suis peu perméable au préjugés
ce n'est pas de la vertu le fruit plutôt
d'une histoire je fus donc stupéfaite
non de l'aveu mais de l'angoisse
profonde qui s'exprimait avec lui ma
réponse fut simple sans doute naïve
j'étais jeune je ne comprenais tout
bonnement pas pourquoi il se mettait
dans un tel état son homosexualité ne me
gênait pas je le prenais et l'aimit tel
qu'il était il me raconta alors sa vie
en parallèle les humiliations au
quotidien sa peur que d'autres
apprennent son
secret nous sommes restés amis bien sûr
aujourd'hui l'étudiant d'hier devenu un
éminent professeur assume son identité
en toute simplicité et son couple quand
je prononçais ici mon intervention lors
de la discussion générale c'est à lui
que je pensais à son visage d'alors
tourmenté par l'aveu mon émotion si vous
l'avez perçu c'est de là qu'elle venait
pas de la perspective des débat qui
s'annonçait lui me suivait par vidéo
interposé des États-Unis nous étions
fiers je crois l'un de l'autre c'est
donc pour lui et parce qu'il m'a tant
appris c'est pour tous ces gay et toutes
ces lesbiennes qui ont à un moment de
leur vie tant souffert de ne pouvoir
simplement dire leur homosexualité c'est
pour tous ceux et toutes celles qui
n'exigent que la banalisation de leur de
leurs conditions qui n'exige que
l'égalité et donc la possibilité de se
marier et de fonder une une famille
c'est pour eux pour elle et pour la
grandeur de notre démocratie que je
voterai avec le groupe écologiste
unanime
ce beau projet de loi et que je
continuerai à me battre pardonnez chers
collègues la tonalité inédite de cette
explication de vote vous savez bien que
je n'en suis pas à mon premier péché
sénatorial j'assume celui là comme les
autres merci voilà c'était donc ce matin
l'intervention ému d''ester Benbassa
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat l'intervention
très personnelle comme l'ont été
d'autres interventions sur les deux
bands de de l'hémicycle depuis ce matin
depuis que se déroule depuis qu'on
commencé les explications de vote autour
du projet de loi mariage pour tous
chacun pour ou contre le texte
intervient de façon finalement assez
personnelle par rapport à son histoire
ou par rapport à des arguments passionné
sur ce projet de loi on va rejoindre
Delphine girérard qui se trouve toujours
dans la tribune de presse de l'hémicycle
Delphine une tonalité assez apaisée hein
par rapport ce matin par rapport aux 8
jours de débat que nous venons de vivre
en direct sur notre antenne oui he bien
sûr pierine vous l'avez dit les débats
sont apaisés on s'écoute dans le respect
on est loin de la tension qui a régné
ici pendant une semaine alors on va tout
de suite rejoindre l'hémicycle car c'est
actuellement l'ancien président UMP de
la commission des lois Jean-Jacques yest
qui s'exprime il ne reste qu'environ
orateurs avant le vote de ce texte para
quand même curieux que sous le prétexte
que il y a des enfants dans cette
situation il faut valider les situations
puisque c'est la volonté d'adultte
la volonté d'adulte qui a fait que ces
enfants se trouvaient dans cette
situation imaginez que pour les mêmes
raisons il y a aussi des enfants qui
sont nés illégalement d'autres manières
est-ce qu'on va valider ce qui est par
exemple des interdictions totales de la
loi et à même un tabou je crois qu'on se
trompe complètement et bien entendu
madame le garde saau si vous commencez à
toucher à l'adoption si vous commencez à
toucher à l'état civil vous touchez
forcément à la ation on a dit non non on
sanctuirise le chapitre du Code civil
sur l'affiliation mais en fait ça ne
tient pas ça ne tient pas demain demain
au nom de la
liberté moi je trouve ça formidable la
liberté ça c'est logique mais que la
liberté des individus à ce momentl ne
demandons pas la société d'encadrer tout
cela
et l'institution du mariage
qui comme le rappelait notre collègue
alfonsier est bien mal et d'ailleurs on
a offert au couple la possibilité de
régler un certain de problèm par la PMA
par la pardon par la par le Pax et bien
oui et beaucoup de jeunes
ménagesutilis cette possibilité
juridique le mariage diminue est-ce
qu'il restera uniquement
seul ceux qui veulent avoir des enfants
des couples
homosexuels et qui soi reconnus comme
leurs enfants est-ce que c'est demain
eux seuls qui se marieront moi je pense
que on est en train de détruire
l'institution du mariage qui jusqu'à
présent était un principe du droit
français et moi je vous l'exigence que
les épouses so un homme et une femme est
conforme au principe d'égalité qui a
valeur constitutionnelle en droit
français nous avons fait des prop
osition nous avons contesté sur le plan
juridique le projet de loi tel qu'il est
et bien entendu je voterai contre ce
projet de loi merci la parole à Madame
virgilie
Cless merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Gard des saau madame la ministre mes
chers collègues l'heure des explications
de vote est arrivée effectivement ce
doit être aussi l'heure de l'apaisement
et du retour de de la
sérénité alors je commencerai par vous
dire Monsieur le Loyen Gillard vous avez
partiellement raison quand vous nous
dites un mariage homosexuel n'est pas la
même chose qu'un mariage hétérosexuel
partiellement parce que aucun mariage
n'est égal à aucun autre mariage qu'il
soit homo ou hétérosexuel parce qu'un
mariage c'est l'aboutissement de
l'histoire de deux individus qui ont
décidé de faire histoire commune qui ont
décidé par amour l'un pour l'autre quel
qu'il soit d'une leur vie et de se
protéger mutuellement jusqu'à la fin et
pour ça ils
viennent devant la loi ils viennent se
mettre à l'abri du droit ils viennent
nous voir pour que l'on célèbre leur
mariage le terme a son importance et ce
n'est pas la même chose qu'une union
civile combien de mariages avons-nous
célébré ceux d'entre nous qui sommes
mares pour lesquels les futures époux
déclarent ne pas avoir déposé de contrat
de mariage autrement dit ils ont fait
confiance au
droit pour se protéger mutuellement et
réciproquement ils ne se sont pas
occupés d'aller voir dans le détail ce
qu'il y avait dans le droit parce qu'ils
font confiance au droit donc le mariage
doit bien être le même pour tous avec
l'ouverture exactement des même droit ou
alors faut-il poser la question au
couples qui viennent nous voir avant de
décider pour eux ou avant de les engager
vers un choix vers une union civile ou
un Pax ou une union libre ou un mariage
avez-vous projet de famille êtes-vous
sûr que vous n'aurez pas projet de
famille FAM dans 5 ans ou dans 10 ans ù
avez-vous passé de famille parce que les
couples qui se marient aujourd'hui des
fois il y a 1 2 3 4 enfants et y compris
parmi les personnes homosexuelles qui
décident aujourd'hui de faire et de
construire leur vie ensemble les enfants
peuvent être déjà là donc ne serait-ce
que pour cette simple raison on ne peut
pas différencier les deux et il faut un
seul mariage qui entraîne exactement les
même droit pour tout le monde alors des
questions de fond pourtant été posé au
cours du débat mais ces questions ce
sont les même pour les couples
homosexuels et pour les couples
hétérosexuels dès lors qu'il s'agit
d'enfant on a beaucoup fait appel à la
nature le désir d'enfant est naturel il
n'est pourtant pas une obligation il
n'est pas une contrainte il n'est pas un
devoir il n'est pas systématique mais il
est naturel on a beaucoup parlé de désir
de droit à l'enfant ou de droit de
l'enfant mais on s'est pas souvent poser
la question de la limite entre les deux
où se trouve la limite entre le droit à
l'enfant et le droit de l'enfant il me
semble à moi qu'on peut se poser la
question de cette limite quand l'enfant
n'est pas encore conçu quand on est en
amont de sa conception en amont de son
existence oui à ce moment-là peut-être
la la limite et la frontière est-elle
encore à construire mais quand l'enfant
est là quand on parle de l'enfant
présent avec nous parmi nous il s'agit
bien là de droit de l'enfant et là sur
les droits de l'enfant les questions une
fois de plus doivent être les mêmes le
mensonge at-on dit l'appellation at-on
dit mais un enfant qui est adopté peut
avoir eu ses deux parents peut avoir
connu ses deux parents peut avoir une
histoire avec ces deux parents un enfant
adopté c'est pas forcément un bébé de
quelques jours ou de quelques mois qui a
tout à apprendre ce peut-être un enfant
de 6 8 10 12 ans qui a une histoire qui
a une culture qui a déjà appelé
quelqu'un maman qui a déjà appelé
quelqu'un papa qu'aura du mal appeler
quelqu'un d'autre fusce une femme maman
de qu'aura du mal appel quelqu'un
d'autre fusce un homme papa 2 cet
enfant-là il trouvera avec ses adoptants
avec la voix de l'amour il trouvera la
façon de l'appeler je connais une petite
fille qui a connu ses parents qui a été
adopté après qui n'a pas voulu appeler
sa deuxème maman était dans un couple
hétérosexuel avec une maman et papa elle
a pas voulu appeler sa deuxième maman
maman elle l'aappelait mamboise
diminutive de Maman et de framboise les
enfants auront cette intelligence du
cœur pour trouver comment il s'appelait
c'est pas un problème en soi le mensonge
le mensonge sur les origines mais la
chose est exactement la même pour les
couples homosexuels que pour les couples
hétérosexuels alors oui avec cette loi
avec cette ouverture de droit à tous au
moins posons-nous les questions et
demain réfléchissons fondamentalement
ouvrons cette porte oui de l'adoption
ouvrons cette porte de cette grande loi
à la famille et aidons les familles à ne
pas mentir à leurs enfants c'est pas oui
le livret de famille est important mais
c'est pas ce que l'on va inscrire dedans
qui permettra ou qui ne permettra pas le
mensonge le mensonge il est avant s'il
faut attendre qu'un enfant soit capable
d'ouvrir un livret de famille de le lire
et de le comprendre pour qu'il sache
qu'il a été adopté alors le mensonge ça
fait longtemps qu'il est là et c'est pas
l'état qu' l'a porté ce sont les parents
donc aidons les parents construisons les
parents et construisons une société
tolérante où tous les parents quel
qu'ils soi on les mêmes droits sont
considérés de la même façon comme des
vrais parents par la société pour
construire une société dans laquelle les
enfants auront des repères de tolérance
et n'auront aucun doute quant à l'amour
que leurs parents leur portent quant au
droit que leurs parents ont pour eux et
quant au devoirs que leurs parents ont
envers eux pour toutes ces raisons bien
évidemment je voterai cette loi et
j'attendrai la suite avec beaucoup
d'impatience et beaucoup d'attention
merci la parole à Monsieur Philippe
B merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministre mes chers collègues nous
avons passé ensemble 8 journées à
traiter de questions qui malgré nos
désaccords sont à coup sûr des questions
qui
touchent aux fondamentaux de la vie
familiale et de la vie en société ce
sont des questions essentielles et je
dois dire que je suis personnellement
très impressionné par la responsabilité
que nous prenons en examinant ce texte
la famille a subi des coups de bouttoir
c'est une évidence au fil des décennies
mais elle résiste heureusement elle
reste aujourd'hui le lieu des
apprentissages fondamentaux le lieu où
se forge une personnalité le lieu de
l'accomplissement aussi et le lieu
où l'on devient finalement citoyen car
c'est la première structure sociale que
l'on découvre en grandissant
les questions que nous touchons sont
aussi des questions qui touchent à
l'intimité la plus grande de tout être
humain son aspiration fondamentale à
aimer à trouver l'être aimé à construire
avec lui une vie commune dont on espère
toujours qu'elle durera toute la vie et
sans doute aussi à travers cette vie
commune l'espérance fondamentale qui est
dans notre cœur que des enfants puissent
sur vir et que l'amour que l'un et
l'autre se porte je parle des deux
adultes va se traduire par un amour
donné à l'enfant qui va lui permettre de
grandir dans les meilleures conditions
et donc quand nous parlons de tout
ceci la polémique naturellement doit
être bien loin et l'exigence de
prudence doit s'imposer à nous je crois
que les uns et les autres nous avons à
cœur de considérer que la loi doit
apporter des réponses au problèmes qui
se posent dans la société et parmi ces
problèmes il y a effectivement
l'expérimentation d'une nouvelle forme
de famille que les intéressés ont eux
même qualifié d'homoparentalité sans
doute pour souligner que cette forme de
famille est effectivement une forme
spécifique de famille et ça n'est pas
manquer d'égard pour toutes ces familles
que de le dire mais puisque c'est une
forme spécifique de famille la question
se pose de savoir si le meilleur cadre
que nous puissions lui offrir c'est
celui
qui a été prévu pour toutes les autres
formes de famille pourquoi pas le débat
méritait d'avoir lieu nous pensons
fondamentalement que ça n'est pas une
bonne chose nous pensons que
l'homoparentalité doit se construire en
vérité et nous pensons que nous ne la
construisons pas en vérité en utilisant
pour la construire le cadre du mariage
avec toutes ces conséquences en terme de
filiation parce que les règles du
mariage du divorce de la filiation n'ont
pas été établis pour permettre à ces
familles de s'épanouir de s'accomplir de
grandir de trouver la stabilité qu'elles
ont besoin il y a au cœur de cette
transposition des conceptions qui me
paraissent fausses je le dis peut-être
d'une manière brutal mais je peux
l'expliquer construire la famille avec
l'enfant selon un modèle dans lequel
l'un des deux parents peut-être le père
bien sûr l'autre parent peut-être la
mère mais s'agissant de couple de même
sexe ils ne peuvent pas tous les deux
être mèr tous les deux être pèr et donc
on invente une troisème forme de parenté
qui consiste à être parent sans être
mère ni être père et nous pouvons
considérer effectivement qu'il y a des
arguments qui vont dans cette direction
tout l'amour qu'on va donner à l'enfant
qui va permettre de le construire et
l'amour que les deux membres du couple
se portent l'un à l'autre mais il y a
aussi quelque chose de fondamentalement
erroné l'ffiliation ne peut pas reposer
seulement sur la biologie mais quand
elle ne repose pas du tout sur la
biologie elle est en fragilité on le
voit bien avec l'assistance médicale à
la procréation on le voit bien avec
l'adoption il faut de grandes
précautions pour russir l'accueil de
l'enfant dans ces deux cas mais quand on
a ni l'altérité sexuelle ni le lien de
la biologie pour construire une famille
alors il faut reconnaître qu'il y a un
père ou une mère mais qu'il n'y a pas de
pères ou de mères et c'est à cause de
cette différence fondamentale de point
de vue que nous avons proposé l'union
civile et que nous refaisons le mariage
des personnes de même sexe l'adoption
l'assistance médicale à l'approcréation
et naturellement la gestation pour
autrui qui qui sont un ensemble et
irrésistiblement nous irons dans cette
direction si nous adoptons cette loi
merci la parole à Madame Marie-Hélène
desego merci monsieur le Président
Madame la gardessau madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues nous arrivons au terme de nos
débats le gouvernement a décidé de
passer Coutte C Coutte malgré notre
opposition malgré l'opposition de
millions de Français qui ont défilé qui
font connaître chaque jour davantage
leur désaccords il ne nous reste plus
donc nous de l'opposition qu'à vous
mettre en garde vous de la
majorité je veux dire qu'avec ce texte
il me semble que nous sommes très loin
de l'intérêt général il y a des zones
d'ombre qui risquent d'entraîner de
graves insécurité juridique vous avez eu
manifestement beaucoup de difficultés à
passer du débat éthique au registre de
la loi au registre du droit sans oublier
personne les oublie ici les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité de ce texte ses
problèmes d'articulation avec le droit
international notre désaccord vienent de
la définition de notre mariage le
mariage n'est pas seulement mes chers
collègues la reconnaissance sociale de
l'amour même entre personnes de sexe
différents c'est une institution qui
inclut la perspective de la procréation
et l'enfant bénéficie d'une filiation
paternelle du seul fait de la loi voilà
le départ de tout et de notre désaccord
voilà à quoi vous vous êtes attaqué
voilà à quoi vous touchez et vous nous
expliquez que c'est au nom de la de
l'égalité votre objectif est de faire un
traitement égal dans la reconnaissance
du sentiment amoureux nous vous l'avons
dit l'égalité signifie seulement de
traiter de même manière ceux qui sont
dans des situations équivalente au
contraire la différence de situation
justifie la différence de traitement en
fait l'égalité n'est toujours corrative
et s'agissant de notre dossier les
couples de personnes de sexes différents
et les couples des de personnes de même
sexe ne sont pas dans la même situation
au regard de la procréation il n'y avait
il n'y aurait pas eu de problème si le
gouvernement avait prévu un texte
seulement sur l'union civile qui aurait
créé un contraste spécifique pour les
couples homosexuels un contrat d'union
civile ouvrant les mêmes droits
patrimoniaux ouvrant offrant même une
protection juridique renforcée l'erreur
est d'être aller d'avoir voulu aller
plus loin de passer à ce que vous avez
appelé un mariage pour tous car derrière
la formule mais c'est un imbrogliot
juridique et un enjeu de société qui
nous sont imposés imposé c'est bien le
terme car c'est un texte sur lequel le
peuple français aurait dû se prononcer
et moi j'ai pas attendu l'intervention
remarquable courageuse de notre collègue
Nicolas Alfonsi pour vous dire ici
qu'aucun sénateur ne peut vraiment
prétendre avoir un mandat de ses
électeurs pour décider ou non not
mariage pour tous donner la parole au
peuple aurait été juste prudent car une
vraie réforme de société ne peut être
pensée réfléchie conçu que de manière
consensuelle en outre ma conviction je
vous l'ai dit c'est que les enfants sont
les grands oubliés de ce texte l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant n'est pas respecté
et ce qui me perturbe véritablement
c'est que le législateur avec votre
texte est en train de décider et de
condamner plusieurs générations à se
voir priver de leur origine où est
l'objectif d'égalité dans tout ça quelle
responsabilité mes chers collègues de
décider pour ces enfants un effacement
délibéré de leurs origines ni les
nouvelles techniques de procréation ni
les innovations juridiques ni le droit
ne peuvent ne doivent aboutir à la
fabrication d'enfant sur simple désir
d'adulte et rien à voir Monsieur
Jean-Vincent blancé avec la situation de
l'adoption que vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure votre situation celle d'un
orphelin qui est recueilli par un père
par une mère mais c'est merveilleux
c'est formidable et nous sommes tous
d'accord avec ça voilà alors ce vote il
en appelle en fait à nos consciences
d'où la gravité de notre séance ce matin
rien à voir avec nos débats
personne respectons chacun car ce débat
touche à l'intime de chacun à sa vie
affective avec sa fécondité ces
blessures c'est haut c'est bas et je
vous ai reproché madame la gardau
gentiment mais fermement c'est vrai de
vous réfugier derrière quelques
citations fameuses derrière cés et bien
d'autres mais derrière ces grandes
personnalités que vous avez cité moi
j'aurais aimé entendre Christian tobira
pour qu'elle nous dise avec toute sa
force de fille de femmes de mère quelle
conviction profonde la guide et je vous
pose la la la question chrisan tbira
n'avez-vous pas peur de prendre la
responsabilité de fracturer une
institution si chère au cœur de nos
concitoyens pour accomplir une réforme
qui en réalité dans sa totalité ne
convient qu'à une toute petite minorité
de français quant à moi Madame la
gardessau mes chers collègues et bien
avec toute ma force de conviction
monsieur le Président en conscience je
vous le dis j'étais favorable l'Union
des couples de personnes de même sexe
mais je demeure fermement opposé à
l'adoption par ces couples à la PMA à la
GPA qui sont en fait dans ce texte
endroit lié je voterai contre ce texte
merci la parole à Charles
Revet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Président ministre mes chers
collègues ce projet de loi je le crains
monsieur le
Président ne fera pasâ dans les annal du
Sénat c'est dommage car ce n'est pas si
souvent que nous avons à légiférer au
fond sur un projet de société il ne fera
pas date pour quelqu'un qui dans 10 ans
20 ans essaiera de relire comment nous
sommes nous avons fait madame le garde
des saau ce changement de civilisation
que vous avez évoqué dans votre
intervention fera date parce
que plutôt une FA pas parce que il y a
eu absence de dialogue absence de débat
bien sûr nous avons eu des auditions je
les souigné monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur nous
avons qui ont été intéressante et
enrichissante mais ce n'était pas le
débat il y a pas eu de débat on a pu
poser des questions mais bien entendu il
y a pas eu débat nous n'avons pas eu de
débat parce que il y avait
absence de la
majorité mes chers collègues absence
physique souvent pu qui abouti à ce
qu'il y ait des votes public à
répétition absence parce que il suffit
de relire combien d'amendements ont été
déposés combien d'intervention vous avez
fait et je trouve que c'est c'est
dommage pour le parlementaire que je
suis je pensais que le Parlement était
justement un lieu de débat en
particulier lorsqu'il y a des problèmes
de société dommage madame le
gardessau on a souligné votre
connaissance du dossier votre écoute et
vos réponses que vous avez fait mais
dommage car peut-être à partir de nos
premières propositions avant l'article
1er et nous aurions pu avoir une
solution acceptable part tous et
correspondant aux attentes des personnes
de même sexe vivant en couple et qui
était me semble-t-il l'engagement du
président de la République sans remettre
en cause les valeurs fondamentales de la
société que chacun euh
reconnaît ça veut dire le mariage la
notion de mariage nous sommes en
désaccord sur ce point parce que la
notion de mariage d'abord
étymologiquement ça a toujours été un
homme une femme qui sont ensemble pour
donner la
vie le mariage surtout parce que à la
clé du mariage il y a ce qui peut en
découler concernant l'adoption
concernant éventuellement la PMA ou la
GPA nous avons sommes en désaccord bien
entendu sur ce qui a été proposé en
terme d'adoption nous sommes en
désaccord parce que Madame le Ministre
de la Famille mais je crois qu'on y
reviendra on a plutôt parlé du désir
d'enfant que du droit de l'enfant or les
droits des enfants devrai être au cœur
de nos préoccupations et je crains que
avec les évolutions qui va intervenir si
ce texte est adopté et
publié les enfants ne soient que
les
derniers dans le la le résultat de de ce
débat que nous avons DAC parce qu'on a
souhaité un référendum vous n'avez pas
voulu su étaé extraordinaire si par
référendum les Français avaient donner
leur avis on sait que à un moment ils
étaient interrogatifs maintenant leur
majorité est contre peut-être madame
garde des
saut- moi je ne désespère jamais qu'à la
relecture de nos débats et dans le souci
d'apaisement qu' a manifesté à plusieurs
reprises le président de la République
et les membres du gouvernement
vous pourrez proposer en regardant ce
que nous avons suggéré puisquil y a pas
eu de débat il y a pas eu d'autres
propositions et bien vous pourriiez
faire dans les le cheminement de ce
projet de loi des propositions qui qui
ferit voir autrement le résultat
notamment je pense bien sûr au
amendements avant l'article 1er je veux
simplement
terminant souligner le travail de
l'ensemble de mes collègues bien sûr
patri jean-jaces yest euh notre
vice-présidente responsable de la
coisation du groupe et tous mes
collègues qui ont fait beaucoup de
propositions qui ont été en fait seuls
dans leur proposition ce qui a été
répondu msieur monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre c'était en fait
l'application de ce qui a été décidé à
l'Assemblée nationale et ça c'est pas un
échange et bien entendu à partir du
moment que nous avons tous c des
acccords nous voterons contre ce texte
merci monsieur le sénateur la parole à
Monsieur Dominique de
leège monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres chers collègues que retenir de
ces 8 jours de débat voilà et comme nous
venons de de le faire il y a quelques
minutes avec l'intervention de d''ester
Ben Bassa que nous avons rediffusé nous
allons maintenant réécouter
l'intervention les explications de vote
de Patrice gellard qui était le
principal orateur du groupe UMP sur ce
texte patri Patrice pardon qui s'est
exprimé aux alentours de 9h ce matin on
l'écoute avec le vote de cette loi nous
sommes maintenant parti sur une barque
qui n'a ni rame ni voile ni gouvernail
ni moteur et qui est parti dans le
brouillard en fait on ne sait pas où on
va avec cette loi qui va être adoptée on
ne sait pas où on va pour plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est qu'elle
est partie d'un prinp p faux de
l'égalité nous n'avons pas cette même
conception que celle qu'on veut nous
imposer qui consiste à dire que
l'égalité quoi qu'il arrive est la même
pour tous quelle que soit leur situation
quel que soi les conditions dans lequell
elle doit s'exercer le deuxè élément
c'est que cette loi repose sur une
analyse qui est insuffisante et qui ne
tient pas compte de l'opinion publique
comme nous l'avons déjà souligné et je
ne comprends pas pourquoi vous pas voulu
écouter les solutions simples que nous
apportions la solution par exemple de
l'union civile qui permettait de
résoudre le problème alors que dans le
projet de loi tel qu'il apparaît et bien
il n'y a pas de véritable mariage il y a
qu'un nersad de mariage qui nous est
proposé et on le verra bien dans la
pratique le mariage des couples
homosexuel n'est pas la même chose que
le mariage des couples hétérosexuels et
ne peut pas être la M même chose de même
vous avez pas tenu compte des
avertissements que nous avons sans cesse
répété concernant
l'inconstitutionnalité de toute une
série de mesures contenues à l'intérieur
de ce texte et ces inconstitutionnalités
n'ont cessé de se développer jusqu'à la
fin en particulier avec la dénégation de
l'article 2 du Code civil qui comme
chacun sait à valeur constitutionnel
alors face à cette situation on nous dit
que et bien maintenant il y aura le
mariage pour tous qui sera le même non
le mariage homosexuel n'est pas le même
que le mariage hétérosexuel et ne sera
pas le même puisque en fin de compte les
règles de filiation ne peuvent pas être
similaires et qu'en plus on est en train
de nous mettre en place un système où
nous aurons des enfants qui auront des
statuts différents selon les cas les uns
seront adoptable de façon plinière les
autres seulement de façon simple les
troisièmes ne pourront pas être adopté
ni par l'un ni par l'autre et résultat
nous allons avoir une situation
d'inégalité qui sera engendrée alors que
là encore nous avions proposé une
solution qui était de nature à
satisfaire tout le monde cette solution
c'était l'adoption simple qu'il fallait
naturellement modernisé et adapté nous
avons proposé un certain nombre
d'amendements pour le faire
malheureusement ils n'ont pas été
acceptés alors alors dans dans quelle
direction nous
orientons bien on constate simplement
qu'avec cette loi qui nous est
aujourd'hui proposée nous allons comme
je le disais en introduction dans le
brouillard dans un brouillard
constitutionnel dans un brouillard
juridique qui remet en cause les
fondements essentiels du contrat social
qui nous unit tous et qui fait qu'on n'a
pas suffisamment réfléchi aux
conséquences que peut avoir ce texte sur
l'ensemble de notre société voilà
c'était ce matin l'intervention du doyen
gelard je le répète le principal orateur
au nom du groupe UMP sur ce projet de
loi mariage pour tous les explications
de vote se poursuivent dans les dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat avant le vote final
sur l'ensemble du projet loi un petit
peu plus tard dans la matinée on va
repartir en séance avec un petit détour
par la tribune de presse où se trouve
toujours dalphine Girard oui un pine
effectivement les explications de vote
continue on a entendu le doyen Patrice
Géard et bien qui regrettait que le
gouver vernement et bien ne tiennent pas
compte de l'opinion publique il faisait
bien évidemment référence aux
différentes manifestations donc contre
ce projet de loi il a également regretté
et bien que le gouvernement n'a pas
retenu sa proposition d'union civile la
proposition de tous les sénateurs de
droite qui a été rejeté il a parlé d'un
NAT de mariage qui allait certainement
être voté alors on retourne tout de
suite dans l'hémicycle pour écouter
l'intervention du sénateur UMP Dominique
de leège il ne reste que très peu de
sénateurs qui vont prendre la parole et
le vote devrait donc intervenir
c'est pourquoi je ne voterai pas cette
loi je voterai cont cette loi merci la
parole est à Monsieur hugle
Portelli bien merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues je
voudrais dire que c'est vrai on l'a tous
dit ce matin en tout cas tous ceux qui
sont dans ces rangs il n'y a pas eu de
vrais débat sur ce texte il n'y a pas eu
de vrais débat même si je dois
reconnaître et je dois remercier madame
le garde des saau et monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission des lois de
nous avoir écouté d'avoir échangé avec
nous même si franchement ils n'ont
strictement rien lâché bon mais bon il y
a eu il y a eu une discussion avec vous
il n'y a pas eu avec avec la majorité il
y en a pas eu il pouvait pas y en avoir
de toute façon il ne pouvait pas y en
avoir pour une raison très simple c'est
que la majorité était obligé de
verrouiller le débat dans ses rangs nous
dans nos rangs je peux vous dire qu'il y
a eu un grand débat très intéressant
passionnant même ouvert démocratique
avec liberté de vote à la clé mais vous
vous ne pouviez pas faire de débat pour
une raison très simple c'est que si on
avait ouvert le débat dans vos rangs la
contradiction éclaté et je voudrais
m'adresser à tous les membres de la
gauche républicaine et laïqu modéré qui
sont nombreux dans vos rangs parce que
le la main que nous vous avons tendu
avec le projet d'union civile vous
auriez dû la reprendre pourquoi pour une
raison très simple c'est que dans votre
texte il y a une adiction intime entre
d'une part l'idée de base qui était la
même que nous c'est-à-dire de donner des
droits équivalents au couple de même
sexe en ouvrant un statut juridique qui
permette de créer et bien une famille
d'avoir des droits et c'était ce que
nous proposions avec l'union civile
qu'on aurait Mme pu appeler autrement
d'ailleurs et puis il y avait ceux parmi
vous qui vou aller beaucoup plus loin
pour quiunion le mariage n'était que le
début d'autre chose et ce début d'autre
chose c'était l'adoption qui le
permettait et ensuite et bien vous le
savez on aurait eu la procréation
médicalement assistée et la gestation
pour autrui et ça c'était la
contradiction qu'il y avait dans V rang
si nous avions pu trouver un compromis
intelligent sur la première et seule
étape sur laquelle nous étions d'accord
et pour écarter le reste et bien il y
aurait eu débat il y aurait eu débat
entre vous et nous il y aurait eu débat
au sein de cette Assemblée vous l'avez
pas voulu vous avez voulu tout
verrouiller pour cette raison alors moi
je vous dis deux choses la première
c'est que de toute façon ce texte vous
allez le voter il va rentrer en vigueur
mais vous allez vous trouver face à deux
difficultés la première c'est que dans
vos rangs le débat va s'ouvrir pour le
coup il va commencer maintenant le débat
que vous avez pas voulu avoir avec nous
vous allez l'avoir dans vos rang et
notamment dans les textes qui vont
arriver que Madame le gardessau nous
promet sur notamment le droit de la
famille et puis la deuxième chose et ça
on vous l'a dit aussi c'est que vous
n'avez pas voulu nous entendre quand
quand nous vous avons dit que vous avez
voulu faire une greffe sur un Tron qui
ne peut pas accepter la greffe parce que
le droit de la famille le droit du
mariage en France il est hérité du droit
romain il ne peut pas récupérer comme ça
par des simples bout de phrase qu'on
ajoute de C de là un droit qui repose
sur une autre logique vous allez avoir
des contradictions c'est pas simplement
l'intelligibilité du texte mais c'est
des questions plus fondamentales que nos
collègues ont soulevé toute cette
semaine notamment sur le le droit de
laaffiliation le droit de l'état de la
personne et ça ben vous allez retrouver
devant le Conseil constitutionnel vous
le retrouverez aussi devant les
tribunaux qui au jour le jour auront à
régler des problèmes et je peux vous
dire que nous nous serons pas les
derniers à mener la bataille juridique
sur ce terrain alors je voudrais
terminer en m'adressant plutôt à ceux
qui pensent comme moi c'est-à-dire ceux
qui pensaient que bien voilà les racines
judéo-chrétiennes de notre société
avaient encore un petit peu de vitalité
que le l'héritage existe encore et bien
c'est fini c'est fini mes chers amis
c'est fini il faut en tirer toutes les
conséquences nous ne sommes plus dans
cette société là c'est comme ça on peut
le regretter nous ne sommes plus dans
cette société là il faudra donc faire
passer nos idées culturelles
spirituelles sociales juridiqu par
d'autres moyens il faut nous les
inventer aujourd'hui mais en attendant
pour ce qui est d'aujourd'hui d'ici et
de maintenant c'est non
merci Monsieur Portelli la parole est à
Jean-Claude Lenoir merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues je lisais avant de
regagner le palis du Luxembourg ce matin
les premiers articles qui étaient
publiés dans la presse nationale sur la
semaine que nous venons de passer il
était fait état d'un d'un débat il n'y a
pas eu de débat il y a eu é change entre
une opposition très mobilisée très
motivée très convaincu et à cet égard je
remercie notre collègue monsieur Hu qui
a souligné notre engagement et la
qualité de cet engagement et devant nous
avons eu bien sûr un gouvernement qui
défendait pied à pied ce texte je salue
à titre
personnel la détermination et la force
de conviction de la ministre des
ministres pardon et notamment de Madame
gardesso même si nous ne part
pas l'idée qu'elle se fait du du mariage
et des textes que nous devons voter et
je veux également dire que cet échange s
poursuivi avec bien sûr les rapporteurs
et le président de la commission des
lois mais devant nous avons eu un groupe
majoritaire qui était ficelé dans une
règle qui avait été imposée il n'y avait
pas le droit d'avoir une opinion
différente de celle qui avait été décidé
en plus haut lieu en plus haut lieu
c'était un engagement du Président de la
République comme si vous
mes chers collègues tenu par tous les
engagements de François Hollande comme
si les français étaient obligés parce
que certains majoritaires avaient voté
pour François Hollande d'accepter tout
ce qu'il avait proposé d'ailleurs il y a
j'allais dire presque une malédiction
sur les engagements transformés en texte
de loi c'est presque une scououn qui
atteint aujourd'hui les engagements
transformés en texte de loi et le
dernier avatar lié à la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel sur la
proposition de loi de Monsieur Brot
relative à la tarification progressive
de l'électricité et du gaz doit vous
interpeller c'est un avatar qui s'ajoute
à combien d'autres alors nous sommes
nous sommes opposés à ce texte nous
votons contre d'abord parce que vous
bouleversez le Code civil la
démonstration a été faite de façon très
brillante par plusieurs de mes collègues
et amis et notamment par le doyen Géard
vous introduisez dans notre système
plusieurs mariages et nous avons noté
que le livret de famille va être
particulièrement riche en
complication aujourd'hui pour qu'une loi
soit applicable comprise
admise doit être d'abord simple elle
doit être intelligible et là vous ouvrez
un champ extrêmement vaste de situation
complexe qui ne sont en fait que des
réponses à une minorité de personnes
influentes qui ont réussi à introduire
dans notre Code civil des dispositions
qui leur convenaient mais en même temps
vous bouleversez la famille vous
bouleversez la famille qui est le socle
et même le pilier central de notre
société simplement parce que vous voulez
que le droit à l'enfant soit reconnu
chacun a son histoire la mienne est
celle très simple d'un enfant qui
appartient à une famille nombreuse qui a
été élevé par un père une mère laquelle
est toujours en vie plus que centenaire
et à qui je dois beaucoup bien sûr
j'admets que d'autres situations a pu
exister mais reconnaissez que notre
société doit beaucoup à la famille à la
famille à celle qui est différente de
celle qui a été un moment dépeinte je
pense erreur par notre rapporteur qui
décrivait la famille idéale aujourd'hui
en opposition à celle qui aurait existé
il y a un siècle mais cette famille à
laquelle je crois est une famille qui
porte des valeurs qui a éduqué des
générations qui a permis aux uns et aux
autres et je pense que c'est l'immense
majorité d'entre nous de vivre
dans un pays apaisé un pays qui savait
mobiliser ses forces vives et son
énergie pour com attre finalement
l'essentiel des défis qui atteignent
aujourd'hui notre société notre monde
alors madame la ministre de la Justice
vous avez eu une phrase qui est
finalement révélatrice vous avez dit
c'est un changement de société qui
accompagne le vote de ce texte je crois
que malheureusement vous avez raison
c'est un vrai changement de société nous
refusons la direction que vous empruntez
et d'autres rendez-vous vont se produire
où nous nous retrouverons et où nous
vous empêcherons si possible de
légiférer sur la GPA sur la PMA mais là
vous avez raison malheureusement c'est
un monde différent que vous êtes en
train de construire et je nai pour le
décrire que cette phrase de Paul Valée
oui le temps du monde finit commence
merci chers
collègue la parole est à notre collègue
Christian
Cambon
madame la présidente madame la ministre
nous voici donc au terme de ce débat
dans quelques minutes madame la ministre
vous pourrez goûter à la satisfaction
d'une promesse tenue enfin une par le
président Hollande quit à avoir perdu le
combat de la morale quit à perdre celui
de la croissance et de la lutte contre
le chômage autant gagner dans les
réformes de société celle-là au moins ne
coûte pas cher
elle donnera au moins cette réforme
satisfaction à un groupe de pression
très branché parisien
LGBT qui sera devenu ainsi le logiciel
de toute pensée en la matière mes chers
collègues de province chers collègues de
gauche de province il vous sera utile de
raconter tout cela dans vos réunions de
MRE croyez-moi le succès vous sera
garanti ainsi ce bel édifice du mariage
qui depuis des siècles a organisé la
rencontre d'un homme et d'une femme pour
construire leur vie ensemble et se faire
ce don
réciproque de concevoir et d'élever un
enfant cet édifice aura vécu vous vous
vous serez obstiné jusqu'au bout à en
détourner le contenu au profit d'une
autre union tout aussi respectable mais
tellement différente l'union de deux
personnes du même sexe au terme de ce
débat c'est un sentiment de triple
gâchie que nombre de collègues
ressentent aujourd'hui gâchie dans la
méthode
effectif minimal de vos groupes
utilisation compulsive du scrutin public
cela ne trompe pas c'est le signe d'un
CAD nassage du débat en d'autres temps
nous avons connu cela en front renversé
nous l'avons payé très cher plutôt que
d'adresser des compliments flatteurs et
fondés à nos chefs de fil madame la
ministre vous auriez été mieux inspiré
de prendre en compte leurs amendements y
a-t-il un autre Parlement démocratique
au monde où une telle réforme d'une
telle importance d'une telle violence
n'aura tenu compte que de deux
amendements mineurs de l'opposition
est-ce cela la France apaisée et unifié
voulu par Monsieur Hollande est-ce cela
président belle la nouvelle démocratie
parlementaire que vous appeliez de vos
vœux lors de vosre élections gâchi sur
le fond aussi ce débat divise les
Français nous aurions pu les réunir en
votant une union civil comme tant
d'autres pays
européens notre majorité en d'autres
temps aurait dû le faire votre majorité
aussi aurait pu mieux faire aujourd'hui
vous allez redonner par ce vote plus de
force et plus d'ampleur à la
protestation qui va grossir le sentiment
de millions de Français de ne pas avoir
été entendu finira par apparaître
aujourd'hui même dans les sondages
demain au fond des urnes alors vous
pouvez ricanner sur ces familles qui
croient encore que l'enfant est un don
et non pas un droit vous pourrez leur
expliquer la société dont vous rêvez
j'ai envie donc j'y ai droit vous
pourrez citer cette constatation gognard
du président sur c'est comme ça c'était
l'autre nuit c'est comme ça la société
change alors faut qu'on change c'est
srement avec des jugements d'une telle
portée que les juristes qui nous
regardent ont écrit quelques règles
intangibles d'un droit que le monde
entier nous envit gâi aussi pour le
Sénat la haute assemblée ne vivra pas
aujourd'hui un de ces jours glorieux
chaque jour du débat nous avons
découvert la portée inquiétante voire
dramatique de certaines dispositions du
texte sur le nom ou le régime d'adoption
notamment et bien plutôt que de répondre
à sa belle mission de 2e chambre en
améliorant ce texte le Sénat s'est
contenté d'être une chambre
d'enregistrement enregistrement de nos
misise en garde de nos appels à aller
vers une réforme nécessaire mais
comprise et accepté par tout le pays
mais vous n'en avez cure l'important
cétait une victoire de gauche pour
laisser au peuple que vous pour laisser
croire au peuple que vous teniez vos
promesses quel qu'en soit le prix alors
maintenant assumez vos responsabilités
mais aprêtez-vous aussi à vivre la suite
du film hier encore le Conseil
constitutionnel vous a sanctionné pour
la 5è fois en 10 mois le combat n'est
pas fini et lorsque le Conseil
constitutionnel aura parlé vous end pas
longtemps pour mesurer le rejet de votre
politique car elle ne résout aucun des
problèmes des Français mais en plus
aujourd'hui elle a divisé la France
merci
monsieurti monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes arrivés au terme
de la discussion sur ce projet de loi à
tous ceux qui répand des rumeurs selon
lesquelles les outremaires feraient
capoter cette loi en raison de leur
nombre et de la faiblesse de la majorité
présidentielle nous avons su démontrer
le contraire par notre présence
constante nos intervention et nouveau
votes je tenais à leur dire qu'il faut
qu'ils arrêtent d'avoir des a prioris
sur les autres m de les considérer comme
des
rétrogrades des conservateurs
nous vivons pour la plupart d'entre nous
dans des parties du monde beaucoup plus
avantgardiste que la vieille
Europe moi-même je vis en guyan en
Amérique du Sud et dans cette partie du
monde nous avons l'habitude de voir des
femmes chefs
d'État
nous le mariage pour tous il est déjà
instauré même dans le propre pays du
pape
actuel donc nous voterons comme nous
l'avons fait durant toute la discussion
ce projet de loi et je tenais à
remercier le gouvernement les ministres
qui ont défendu ce projet de loi le
rapporteur la commission des lois et
tout particulièrement avec beaucoup de
fierté pour moi qui suis guanais pour
mon collègue Antoinette notre ministre
patriote Christian toubira merci merci
la parole au président Gérard larch
oui monsieur le président madame la
garde des saut madame la ministre mes
chers collègues nous venons de partager
pendant 8
jours ce que je peux qualifier moi de
débat parlementaire et d'un débat
parlementaire qui entre le projet du
gouvernement a été en fait comme une
balle de pelote bass renvoyé par un
fronton qui été le fronton des deux
groupes de l'opposition ici au Sénat et
fondé notamment sur quatre motions
motion du président gellard motion
présentée par le président yest motion
présenté par r Portelli puis par Bruno
rotaillot et au fond c'est ce qui a
fondé notre débat face au projet du
gouvernement et je voulais vraiment
remercier l'ensemble de nos collègues
parce que sinon je le crois bien nous on
pas eu ce débat et qui s'est en même
temps exercé pour le groupe auquel j'ai
l'honneur d'appartenir et je le remercie
dans la liberté de choix de chacun et
c'est un point extrêmement important car
aucun mandat n'est impératif et chacun
décide en conscience de son vote et de
son
choix vous savez au fil du 20e siècle
qui fut sans doute le plus chaotique le
plus tragique pour les différences
nous avons cheminé vers l'acceptation
puis le respect de nos
différences ce fut notamment le cas pour
l'orientation sexuelle et c'est pour moi
un signe de progrès de
civilisation sur ce point un peu comme
le disait Rabo Saint-Étienne en août
1789 de la liberté de conscience et
c'était dans les débats préalable à la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nous sommes passés
de la tolérance qui est
condescendance à la liberté qui est
respect et Jean-Pierre affarin le
rappelait tout à l'heure et bien je dois
vous dire qu'à la différence légitime au
nom d'une conception réductrice de
l'égalité l'égalité extrême qu'évoquit
Nicolas alphonsi vous répondez par
l'uniformité d'une institution fondée
sur l'altérité le mariage
comme si au nom des principes essentiels
on ne devait pas considérer comme aussi
essentiel des valeurs fondatrices
l'enfant et c'est vraiment en
participant très largement ce débat en
l'écoutant au fond je me dis au bout de
ce débat l'enfant est vraiment le
fondement de notre société
et que ça soit au
travers de l'adoption de
laaffiliation de son nom de sa famille
du nom qui est un sujet qui pour moi
s'est révélé au cours du débat qui fait
que chaque personne est à la fois unique
mais s'inscrit dans une continuité et
que c'est sans doute ça la dimension
d'humanité spécifique qui c à ce débat
alors tous ces fondements vont sortir
bouleversés sans boussole de nos débats
une institution déjà fragiliser le
mariage va en sortir lesésardé et bien
d' dans quelques que moi dans quelques
années viendront d'autres débats qui
porteront sur l'essentiel et sur le
caractère du don que nous avons évoqué
dans nos débats alors c'est vraiment en
conscience et au-delà de ce qui peut
être j'allais dire quelqu'un qui se
situe clairement dans l'opposition à la
politique qui est conduite c'est
vraiment en conscience et j'allais dire
avec la liberté de mon mandat que je
voterai contre ce texte merci la parole
au président
françoissamen
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres chers collègues voilà nous
voilà au terme de de 8 jours de de débat
plus de 60 he d'échange nous voilà au
terme de l'examen de ce texte qui doit
ouvrir le mariage au couple de même sexe
si
j'avoue reconnaître par moment avoir
connu par moment un peu de
l'assitude je voulais dire à nos
collègues que nous étions tout à la fois
là
présents mais un peu là un peu là de un
peu là de de vous entendre quelquefois
répéter en boucle les mêmes
arguments plus de 200 explications de
vote
certaines très originales intéressantes
mais beaucoup d'autres
reprenantassablement les mêmes arguments
mais je voulais dire à nos collègues que
que je respecte bien évidemment je vouis
dire à nos collègues que je n'ai jamais
ressenti si j'ai éprouvé de la lassitude
ni découragement ni inquiétude et
surtout jamais aucun doute parce que je
savais que nous voterions ce texte en
effet comment comment se décourager
quand on lutte pour une cause juste en
tous les cas nous la pensons juste et
pour faire cesser inégalité et
discrimination qui frappe certains de
nos concitoyens encore en ce moment en
raison de leurs orientations
sexuelles comment douter comment douter
quand on combat pour les valeurs qui
fondent notre République et elles ne
sont pas je voudrais le dire à notre
collègue elles ne sont pas dévalorisé la
liberté reste une grande valeur
l'égalité est la plus belle de toutes et
la fraternité doit nous rassembler à
travers la laïcité oui la liberté la
liberté de vivre ensemble à l'instant
même et les jours qui viennent de
s'écouler l'ont prouvé où certains de
nos concitoyens ont été poursuivis voire
pourchassés en raison de leurs
orientations sexuelles et cela n'est pas
tolérable l'égalité l'égalité des des
droits quel plus beau quelle plus belle
perspective et puis la fraternité la
fraternité face aux différences la
fraternité qui doit nous rassembler dans
la laïcité de la République la laïcité
car l'institution du mariage
n'appartient à aucune religion elle
appartient à la République alors comment
enfin s'inquiéter pourquoi s'inquiéter
quand la gauche se rassemble pour
combattre en faveur des valeurs
républicaines à nos collègues à nos
collègues deux remarques rapides
cursives vous nous avez opposé j'ai
entendu encore dernièrement madame
desego l'intérêt supérieur des enfants
ainsi vous seriez les défenseur de
l'intérêt supérieur des enfants et nous
alors et nous alors alors même que vous
avez supprimé la défenseur du droit des
enfants sans que vous ne disiez
rien à notre collègue
ier ministre
ave vous avez dit que vous vouliez être
le camp du N au nominatif belle belle
formule mais j'ai entendu d'autres de
vos collègues dire que vous étiez en
réalité le camp du nom non le camp du
refus du progrès et moi je préfère je
préfère je préfère cette gauche qui
rassemblé ici s'est battu pour mettre
fin aux discrimination dont était frappé
à la pénalisation dont était frappé les
homosexuels autour du sénateur kayavet
ici même je préfère cette gauche qui a
su imposer le Pax contre vous avec une
violence de résistance à l'époque que
vous regrettez aujourd'hui je préfère
cette gauche qui va dans quelques
instants donner au coupes homosexuel au
couple de même sexe la possibilité de se
marier voilà mes chers collègues en
quelques mots la fierté qui nous envahit
les uns les autres en vous remerciant en
vous remerciant de la part que vous avez
pris au débat mais quand nous sommes
favorables à un texte à un texte qui
fait avancer ses droits avec cette
noblesse et que nous écoutons la garde
des saut la ministre de la Famille que
nous sommes d'accord avec eux c'est par
notre présence physique que nous leur
avons apporté notre soutien merci merci
merci après ces explications de vote je
vais donner la parole au commissions a
travailler sur le projet de loi madame
la rapporteur de la commission oui
monsieur le Président madames les
ministres chers collègues moi j'ai envie
de dire que ce matin et bien c'est à
l'image de ce que nous vivons depuis
plusieurs jours et plusieurs nuit une
image concentrée qui donne bien une une
vision différente d'un côté des propos
alarmistes
alarmants pessimistes parfois prédictif
d'un monde que l'on sait ne se produira
pas ce ne sera pas ni la révolution ni
le chaos quand on regarde les autres
pays en Europe qui ont ouvert ce droit
au mariage et encore cette semaine un
peu plus loin en Amérique du Sud on voit
bien que c'est pas ce qui se présage
mais vous voulez faire peur c'est sûr
que cette vision que vous avez de la
famille vous sentez vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure perdre un peu pied et c'est au
nom des mêmes valeurs que vous dans
l'intérêt de l'enfant que nous aussi on
défend de ce côté une vision plus
progressiste plus inclusive incluante de
toutes les familles et de toutes celles
et ceux qui veulent faire famille quel
que soit leur orientation sexuelle donc
moi je remercie toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ont contribué à à faire que
cette loi voit le jour aujourd'hui et je
m'apprête avec fierté et avec conviction
à la votter merci monsieur le rapporteur
de la commission des lois
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues bien sûr
vous le comprendrez c'est avec beaucoup
de fierté d'émotion que je savoure ce
moment 15 ans après l'adoption du Pax et
je remercie mon groupe le groupe
socialiste et la commission des lois qui
m'ont désigné qui ont voté pour que je
fasse ce rapport et je suis redevable la
confiance que m'ont fait François
repsamen et Jean-Pierre suur de faire en
sorte que je participe à une histoire
qui n'est pas finie vous l'avez tous dit
non l'histoire n'est pas finie elle se
poursuivra par des améliorations
constantes parce que c'est ça notre
société oui il y a eu un débat mes chers
collègues ici mais il y a eu un débat
sur nos propositions bien sûr c'est
normal sur les propositions du
gouvernement car les vôtres mon cher
collègue C d'union civile mais elles
sont dépondées elles sont dépassées en
disant vous avez raté des étapes vous
navez rien fait si peut-être aujourd'hui
nous étions arrivés avec un texte
différent de celui du Pax les choses
auraient peut-être été autrement on
aurait peut-être pu voter d'autres
dispositions vous ne l'avez pas fait
vous avez perdu la main et bien
aujourd'hui acceptez que ce soit le
gouvernement et François Hollande qui
prennent la main et qui propose cette
réforme majeure au français alors je
voudrais remercier bien sûr toutes
celles et tous ceux qui m'ont aidé dans
ce rapport mon collaborateur les
collaborateurs du groupe socialiste bien
sûr les services de la Commission des
lois le directeur des le nouveau
directeur des
services on peut le dire et puis les
administrateurs qui ont plus
particulièrement travaillé avec moi
Olivia Terzian et et Sébastien
Miller un salut bien entendu un salut
affectueux j'allais dire à nos ministres
madame Bertinotti et Madame tobira
saluer leur la connaissance du dossier
vous me direz c'est le moins qu'on
puisse faire mais enfin bon faut quand
même le dire c'est pas toujours le cas
ça na pas toujours été le cas mais
surtout leur engagement profond et leur
Foug pour défendre les idées qui sont
les nôtres aujourd'hui et qui doivent
être défendu enfin je voudrais envoyer
un salut amical à herward bet qui vient
de nous appeler à l'instant puisqu'il va
continuer poursuivre et peut-être
achever le travail qui a été entrepris à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a quelques
mois et puis avoir une pensée pour
toutes seul et T ceux que je connais ou
que je ne connais pas mais qui attendent
avec impatience le jour où enfin ils
pourront se marier merci merci
mes chers collègues je mets au voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage au couple de personnes de même
sexe ceux qui sont favorables pour
l'adopter lève la
main merci ceux qui sont
contre merci
abstention mes chers collègues le Sénat
a adopté le projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage au couple de personnes
Mme
se je passe la parole à présent à
Monsieur Jean-Pierre suur président de
la commission des
lois mes chers collègues un mot
seulement pour vous
dire
si vous voulez bien merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres mes chers
collègues je voulais d'abord dire c'est
vrai à mon tour la grande émotion qui
est la nôtre et je voulais me tourner
vers
l'avenir me tourner vers l'avenir en
disant que l'avenir maintenant que ce
texte est adopté ici et qu'il le sera
bientôt à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est c'est pour beaucoup
d'hommes et de femmes homosexuel à qui
je
pense ces hommes et ces femmes qui ont
vécu dans des situations où ils étaient
constamment
vilipandés constamment critiqué et qui
ont tellement vécu longtemps dans la
honte qui ont demander la
reconnaissance et ce texte c'est d'abord
un texte de reconnaissance pour elle et
pour eux ils ont
demandé depuis bien des années que l'on
puisse passer de la honte à la fierté
que chacun et chacune dans ce pays
puisse avoir la fierté d'être qui il est
et d'être respecté dans son être propre
cela c'est le premier avenir qu'il y
aura après le vote de ce texte
deuxièmement ce texte il est voté comme
il est et dans l'écriture qui est la
sienne et à cet égard je tiens à dire
que tous les procès qui ont été fait
constamment puisquon nous a dit pendant
des heures que ce texte portait sur
autre
chose que ce qui est son
objet et bien ce n'est pas vrai ce texte
il est voté comme il est il parle du
mariage il parle de l'adoption sur les
autres sujets premièrement il est clair
que nous aurons encore à travailler et à
réfléchir aucune position n'est prise
sur les sujets qu'on nous a constamment
envoyé comme étant impliqué par le texte
et sur l'adoption il y a un accord
général je tiens le dire ici pour que
dans la loi famille qui va venir il y a
un grand volet pour qu'on revoit la
totalité de la législation sur
l'adoption dans notre pays je voulais
dire cela avec confiance et pour
terminer je veux aussi très simplement
remercier de tout cœur nos rapporteurs
Jean-Pierre Michel et Michel Menier pour
leur générosité pour le temps qu'ils ont
passé pour leur sincérité pour la force
de leur conviction et je me permettrait
aussi de remercier bien sûr à mon tour
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont
participé notamment les collègues de la
commission des lois et pour finir nos
deux ministres cher Dominique bertinoti
et Cher Christiane tobira pour cette
même force de votre conviction ça fait
plaisir quand la politique est portée
par le cœur et par l'esprit merci merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente trunley
oui monsieur le Président je
souhaiterais vous faire porter une liste
des collègues qui souhaitaent voter pour
le texte et s'abstenir et je voudrais
que cela puisse figurer dans le
compte-rendu
du du du JO
oui oui bien sûr madame la Présidente
vous
avez lu la liste par votre intervention
donc j'en prends acte madame la ministre
pardon madame le ministre je vais vous
demander de patienter quelques secondes
monsieur le Président repamè oui même
monsieur le Président pardon je souhaite
en faire de même monsieur le Président
très bien très bien je vous remercie
monsieur monsieur des trigne oui oui oui
attendez attendez madame ass c'est au
fur à mesure des doigts qui se lèvent
madame
dtrag alors voilà voilà hein d'ailleurs
il fallait que je la f je ne suis pas
marié suis pas marié donc nous
connaissons pas Madame D monsieur des a
la parole merci monsieur le Président
oui je je fais la même demande au nom au
nom du groupe udi Union
centriste on va se suivre pour dire
exactement la même chose donc je demande
aussi que les les collègues du groupe
CRC qui ne sont pas là mais qui ont ont
fait le choix de voter en faveur de de
de de ce texte soit inscrit puisque
l'ensemble de mon groupe votera pour ce
texte merci madame la Présidente même si
vous m'avez fait trébucher tout à
l'heure Monsieur
Robert monsieur le Président même même
proposition pour le groupe RDSE
naturellement qu'on puisse donner le
vote de
chacun monsieur placé
oui monsieur le Président même demande
pour le groupe écologiste qui comme le
groupe CRC est unanime mais je crois que
pour un tel moment chacune et chacun de
nos collègues aura le le souci d'être
présent dans le compre-rendu pour pour
cette belle journée merci à vous merci
madame la ministre avec mes
excuses monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs et
sénateurs et sénatrices vous dire
évidemment que c'est un moment
d'émotion nous en avons vécu déjà un
premier avec Christian tobira lors du
vote par l'Assemblée nationale en voilà
un deuxième tout aussi important tout
aussi fort et je voulais dire que en
écoutant ces ces débats j'ai entendu
souvent que le peuple était convoqué
dans cette assemblée je voudrais
simplement dire que respecter le le
peuple c'est d'abord le respecter dans
sa diversité et que il n'est pas
possible de vouloir imposer à l'ensemble
de la société un seul modèle familial ce
n'est pas ce que nous demandent nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui il y a une
diversité des modèles familiaux et nos
concitoyens dans leur grande diversité
nous demande de leur accorder les mêmes
droits et les mêmes devoirs et
contrairement à ce que vous pensez c'est
bien nous qui sommes en train de
défendre la famille même si cette
famille présente des visages multiples
c'est le choix de nos concitoyens nous
devons en tant qu'État leur assumer les
mêmes droits et les mêmes devoirs je
voudrais me tourner vers Esther Benbassa
pour lui dire combien j'étéis touché par
ses propos j'ai été touché par ces
propos parce que j'ai vécu au travers de
mes fonctions antérieur comme mèire
d'arrondissement des
situations humaines très proches de Cell
qu'elle a évoqué avec beaucoup de cœur
effectivement j'ai eu l'occasion
d'entendre nombre d'homosexuels faire
part de leurs souffran de leur lutte
contre eux même de honte parce que
vivant dans une société qui hier je
l'espère tolérait plus les homosexuels
qu'elle ne les accepait et qui explique
encore il ne faut jamais l'oublier un
taux de suicide bien trop élevé chez les
jeunes homosexuels et au fond cette loi
et bien c'est une façon et c'est cela
qui est à mettre à votre honneur c'est
leur enfin leur donner le droit
d'exister sereinement dans une digité
retrouvé c'est une loi qui va leur
permettre de ne plus être clandestin
dans leur famille de ne plus être
clandestin dans la société de ne plus
être clandestin dans la République enfin
je voudrais dire et c'est dommage je
vais me tourner vers monsieur rafarin
c'est cette loi n'a pas vocation ni à
assurer le paradis social ni à engendrer
l'enfer spirituel c'est une loi qui se
veut tout simplement
permettre d'offrir à chacun de nos
concitoyens quelle que soit leur
orientation sexuelle d'être des citoyens
à part entière dotés des mêmes droits et
des mêmes devoirs et je vais pour
conclure me tourner vers madame desg
pour lui dire que en conscience comme
fille comme mère comme citoyenne je
partage pleinement ce propos d'une mère
que nous avons auditionné et qui nous
dit qui nous interpellait en nous disant
comment justifier auprès de mes deux de
mes deux garçons dont l'un est
homosexuel qui n'est pas les mêmes
droits et bien moi je réponds en
conscience qu'il n'y a aucune
justification effectivement et je peux
vous dire la fierté immense que j'ai à
partager avec vous tous sénateur et
sénatrices qui avaient voté pour cette
loi car c'est un grand moment une
véritable avancée pour l'ensemble de
notre
société merci je passe la parole à
Madame Christian tobira garde des saau
ministre de la Justice monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de la
commission des lois madame la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur sur le fond
madame la rapporteur pour avis mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je dois dire qu'il y a dans cet
hémicycle en cet instant en chacun
d'entre nous une émotion profonde mais
une émotion si profonde si forte qu'elle
emplit les micycles lui-même puisque
nous ressentons bien le climat
qui nous enveloppe en ce moment
particulièrement
important je veux avant d'évoquer
brièvement quelques éléments majeurs de
ce texte
saluer saluer les présidents des groupes
parlementaires des groupes de la
majorité Monsieur François repsamen et à
travers lui l'ensemble des sénatrices et
des sénateurs du groupe socialiste je
veux saluer le la présidente madame la
Présidente Ian Assassi du groupe
CRC je veux aussi saluer à travers elle
évidemment les sénatrices et les
sénateurs du groupe salut le président
Jacques mzard du groupe RDSE
et cher Robert R qui avait été fortement
présent pendant ces débats remercier et
saluer l'ensemble des sénatrices et
sénateurs du groupe Jean-Vincent placer
président du groupe des sénatrices et
sénateurs verts et à travers vous aussi
tous à la fois pour votre engagement
pour votre constance et pour votre sens
du travail commun malgré parfois des
divergence d'appréciation une capacité à
faire vivre ce texte à l'enrichir qui
fait que nous allons sortir des deux
chambres avec un beau texte je veux dire
aux sénatrices et aux sénateurs de la
majorité à quel point j'ai été sensible
à la rigueur avec laquelle ils ont
participé aux travaux
préparatoires à la très grande qualité
de vos
interventions lors de la discussion
générale à la dignité avec laquelle vous
avez participé au débat sur les motions
de procédure ainsi que sur les articles
et parce que j'ai été parlementaire
moi-même je sais à quel point on peut
brûler d'envie d'intervenir pendant les
échanges et je sais comment vous avez
résisté stoïquement à la tentation
d'intervenir
évidemment pour vos convictions mais
aussi avec le souci légitime de faire
connaître à vos électeurs vos prises de
position cette amnégation qui vous a
conduit à participer à ce débat à être
présent et à consommer très peu de temps
à l'économiser au contraire est un sens
des responsabilités que je veux saluer
particulièrement et je veux vous dire
merci pour votre présence active et
stimulante je je veux
saluer les sénatrices et sénateurs de
l'opposition qui ont fait vivre ce débat
vous saluez madame
trinely qui ne doit pas être bien loin
oui c'est ce sont les contraintes de la
polyvalence enfin de la haute
responsabilité la vigilance avec
laquelle elle a assuré les intérêts du
groupe la défense du groupe pendant C
euh plus que semaines de débat ces 8
jours de
débat permettez que je m'incline en
particulier devant le doyen Géard devant
le président yest devant le Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre affarin permettez
que je les salue d'une marque
particulière compte tenu de la qualité
de leurs interventions de toute la
charge qu'ils ont mise dans l'effort
pour veilleer quand même à ce que nous
ayons un texte de qualité et s'assurer
du respect de ce texte à l'égard des
dispositions de notre loi
fondamentale puisqu'il n'y aura plus de
temps de repost je veux vous dire Madame
desg contte tenu de votre réaction la
dernière fois que je salue votre
pugnacité vous m'avez interpellé en
qualité de
fille de mère et de
femme j'père que femme en tant que moi
pour moi vous avez donc omis ma qualité
d'épouse qui fut un temps et même qui
fut de
fois ce que je ressens madame la
sénatrice mais justement c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire vous me faites une
interpellation dans cet hémicycle je
suis ici en qualité de garde des saau je
porte un texte du Gouvernement je le
porte sans la moindre réticence je le
porte avec une incontestable fierté je
le porte avec toutes mes
convictions et je le porte avec le souci
surtout surtout de la
rigueur indispensable à l'écriture de la
loi parce que la loi est une règle
commune et que elle vise à protéger les
citoyens donc il n'y a aucune nécessité
de s'interroger sur ce que ma personne
peut avoir à faire dans cette affaire ma
personne n'est aucunement en
contradiction avec le contenu de ce
texte de loi mais c'est en
responsabilité et en conscience de cette
responsabilité qu'en qualité de garde
des saut j'ai présenté ce texte devant
vous je veux saluer euh Dominique
Bertinotti pour sa présence sa forte
implication la qualité de ses
interventions sa
combativité et pour lui dire qu'elle a
sans doute mesuré l'attente
extraordinaire qui pèse sur elle pour ce
texte qu'elle aura le plaisir et
l'honneur de présenter devant les
Chambres du Parlement
prochainement je veux saluer il n'est
pas avec nous aujourd'hui mais il est
venu par respect pour vous à plusieurs
reprises Alain vidalis ministre des
Relations avec le
Parlement la commission des lois et la
commission des Affaires social ont fait
un travail en commun en bonne
intelligence également bonne
intelligence avec le rapportte
de l'Assemblée nationale il y a là une
exemplarité dans la méthode de travail
entre les deux
chambres nous ouvrons l'institution
républicaine du mariage au couple de
même
sexe la force et la puissance de la loi
consistent à énoncer des règles
générales qui puissent couvrir toute la
diversité des situations et anticiper
sur la complexité des L
et nous savons à quel point
l'imagination des hommes et des femmes
est
infinie pour compliquer les litiges
notamment lorsque les sentiments sont en
cause et la force et la puissance de la
loi est d'être capable
d'anticiper les règles nécessaires pour
répondre à ces situations dont certaines
sont imprévisibles et C ouverture de
l'institution du mariage au couple de
même sexe se fait dans les mêmes
conditions que pour les couples hosexuel
dans les mêmes conditions d'âge et de
consentement avec les mêmes obligations
de respect d'assistance de fidélité avec
les mêmes sécurités par les effets
d'ordre public et les conséquences sur
le régime social au régime fiscal avec
les mêmes protections
aussi parce que en cas de séparation en
cas de conflit le juge interviendra le
juge interviendra pour protéger le du
couple ou de la famille le plus
vulnérable le plus fragile il
interviendra pour veiller à l'intérêt
des enfants il interviendra pour
s'assurer que ces adultes pris dans le
vertige d'un conflit et qui souvent
deviennent draisonnabl à ces moments-là
ne perdent ni leur dignité ni leur
droits ni le sens des devoir qu'il
demeurent et surtout qu'il puissent
continuer à veiller sur leurs enfants et
je parle d'enfants oui je parle
d'enfants mais d'enfants d'enfants qui
vivent et qui existent de ces enfants
qui sont dans ces
familles de ces enfants qui sont faits
de chair d'eau qui sont tous vibrants de
cris de rire de ces enfants qui
s'écorchent au genou de ces enfants qui
aiment les secreries qui détestent les
brocolis de ces enfants qui nous
explosent la tête de ces enfantsl ce
sont eux que vous protégez avec ce texte
de
loi et puis vous protégez aussi les
ces adolescents qui vous le savez à ces
moments particuliers où la personnalité
s'épanouit dans des élans et des
tensions parfois contradictoires sont
déjà dans le trouble et doivent
affronter le trouble supplémentaire de
regard de parolle de gestes qui signent
leur exclusion de la
société par ce texte vous leur dit qui
sont pleinement citoyens dans ce pays
qui sont adolescents comme les autres
adolescents qui's ont leurs singularités
leurs individualités comme les autres
adolescents et que pour le reste le
reste c'est leur
affaire le reste c'est leur affaire et
nous y veillons avec une vigilance sans
faille en votant ce
texte nous consolidons et nous
renforçons vous avez consolidé et vous
avez renforcé le pacte
républicain le pacte républicain la
respublica la chose publique le bien
commun et qu' a-t-il de plus précieux
comme bien commun que nos institutions
et en ouvrant cette institution
républicaine aux coupes de même sexe
nous reconnaissons tout simplement leur
pleine
citoyenneté vous dites tout simplement
que ces personnes qui décide de se
mettre ensemble autour d'un projet
conjugal d'un projet parental que ces
personnes-là ont exactement les mêmes
droits que tous les autres citoyens et
ainsi vous contribuez à la paix civile
et je le dis ici je le dis ici dans
cette haute assemblée qui est si attaché
aux libertés
individuelles à leur défense à leur
préservation et vous avez su le faire
parfois contre le gouvern que vous
souteniez mais cette haute assemblée qui
a parfois quelques problèmes avec les
mœurs et c'est vrai qu'avec le mariage
des couples de même sexe nous sommes à
la croisée des libertés individuelles et
des murs et je dis bien des meurs je ne
parle pas d'évolution de murs
l'homosexualité a toujours existé nous
consentons au murs et à la croisée des
libertés individuelles et des mœurs nous
acceptons
effectivement de faire un pas
supplémentaire vers l'égalité en ouvrant
cette institution républicaine au couple
de même sexe parce qu'ainsi nous faisons
en sorte qu'ils deviennent des citoyens
comme les autres que nous n'avons pas à
distinguer leur orientation sexuelle et
à en faire un marqueur de leur personne
ce sont pleinement des citoyens personne
ne se fusquera que je salue en
particulier les parlementaires des outr
mes parce que comme tout les
parlementaires de la majorité ils ont
consenti à être présents à être actifs à
stimuler notre travail à nous
accompagner à nous encourager et en même
temps à économiser le temps alors que
ils ont traversé au moins un océan pour
être présent et assister à ces débats je
veux les remercier particulièrement
parce qu'ils ont fait preuve de courage
cont tenu de l'ambiance qui a été
entretenue ces dernières semaines dans
les territoires des
outremèes
mesdames les sénatrices mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs de l'opposition
merci pour la très très grande qualité
de la plupart de vos interventions pour
l'enrichissement de ce débat mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
de la majorité mesdames les sénatrices
et messieurs les sénateurs de
l'opposition qui avveent voté ce texte à
vous toutes et à vous tous merci
chaleureusement parce que en votant ce
texte vous nous avez conduit dans ce
lieu à la fois symbolique et social
décrit par Rabin
bratat
Tagor le grand Tagor ce lieu symbolique
et social là où l'esprit est sans
crainte et où la tête est oportée là où
la connaissance est libre là où le Clair
courant de la raison ne s'abîme pas dans
la ride et mort désert de la coutume
merci merci mes chers
collègues permettez-moi de vous
remercier à mon tour chacune chacun
d'entre vous sur tous les bancs y
compris ceux du gouvernement pour la
qualité de vos interventions pour un
débat qui je le crois honore le Sénat
mes chers collègues l'ordre du jour du
lundi 15 avril 2013 à 16h et le soir
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi
relatif à l'élection des conseillers
municipaux départementaux communautaires
et modifiant le candrier électoral
conclusion de la CMP sur le projet de
loi organique relatif à l'élection des
conseillers municipaux intercommunaux
départementaux la séance est levée et
voilà séance levée projet de loi mariage
pour tous adopté par le Sénat il y a une
dizaine de minutes de ça un vote à
mainlevée donc on n' pas encore le
détail de ce scrutin savoir qui a voté
pour qui a voté contre on le saura on le
verra dans le compte-rendu qui sera
publié puisque les différents groupes
politiques du Sénat ont demandé à ce que
soit mentionné effectivement quel les
sénateurs qui ont voté pour ou contre
vous avez pu l'entendre à l'instant sur
notre antene le discours également sans
note he comme d'habitude de la Garde
DESS saau Christian tobira qui s'est
longtemps exprimé sur son émotion après
l'adoption du projet de loi par le Sénat
elle a beaucoup insisté également sur la
garantie accordée aux enfants et elle
s'est porté effectivement garante de des
droits des enfants alors pour revenir un
peu sur ce vote sur les explications de
vote on rejoint Delphine Girard en
tribune de presse oui merci pine et bien
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le mot qui
a dominé et bien c'est l'émotion ils
sont plusieurs avoir fait part de leur
émotion on vient de l'entendre la garde
des saau qui a parlé de sa profonde
émotion elle a également estimé que par
ce vote et bien les sénateurs renforcé
le pacte républicain Dominique bertinoti
a également fait part de son émotion
estimant que ce vote était une avancée
elle a rappelé que le taux de suicide
chez les jeunes homosexuels était
particulièrement élevé émotion aussi du
côté de Jean-Pierre sieur il a dit que
cette politique était porté par le cœur
et par l'esprit il a salué la garde des
saau et la ministre délégué à la famille
quant à Jean-Pierre Michel il a fait
part quant à lui et bien de sa fierté de
son émotion 15 ans après avoir défendu
le Pax il a estimé et bien que les
propositions de la droite étaient démodé
dépassées vous n'avez rien fait en
disant a-t-il dit pour lui ce vote est
une réforme majeure alors du côté et
bien de l'opposition on a entendu des
arguments d'un tout autre niveau par
exemple Jean-Pierre rafarin a parlé et
bien d'une faute politique Bruno
retaillot d'un engrenage qui allait
mener à la gestation pour autruie quand
à Patrice gellard et bien il a évoqué un
azat de mariage plusieurs sénateurs de
droite ont également mise en cause le
gouvernement contre une censure à venir
du Conseil constitutionnel ils ont ont
beaucoup fait allusion à la à la censure
qui a frappé la loi brud sur le bonus
malus de l'énergie et puis on a
également entendu les arguments de
Chantal Joanot qui a défendu sa position
minoritaire au sein de son groupe
également de l'émotion du côté de
Jean-Vincent placer le président du
groupe écologiste du Sénat qui a fait
part de son histoire personnelle
rappelant qu'il était orphelin et qu'il
savait lui et bien ce qu'était
l'adoption voilà et bien pour un petit
résumé he de toutes les explications de
vote on vous retrouve tout de suite pine
avec Jean-Pierre belle merci beaucoup
ine Gérard pour toutes ces interventions
en direct de la tribune de presse dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat Jean-Pierre Bell le
président du Sénat est avec nous en
direct bonjour quel est votre état
d'esprit après l'adoption par le Sénat
de ce projet de loi aujourd'hui bien je
suis d'abord très heureux de voir que le
Sénat a montré une image qui est tout à
fait celle que les Français je crois
aujourd'hui attendentune assemblée comme
la nôtre voilà la garde des SA a salué
la dignité des débats ici vous partagez
ce sentiment je je le partage pleinement
les interventions il faut le dire étai
de de de qualité nous avons su aussi
maîtriser le temps parlementaire de
manière à montrer que sur un sujet qui
on le voit bien peu divisé et bien nous
étions capables de nous exprimer en
sérénité et aussi mener à son terme un
beau débat vous estimez que les débats
ont été suffisamment longs pour que
chaque position puisse s'exprimer oui je
crois que 6 jours entiers de de de débat
je crois que vraiment la question ne se
pose même pas les les les débats ont été
riches tous ceux qui ont voulu sont se
sont exprimés longuement et je crois que
personne peut se sentir frustré de ce
point de vuelà il y a eu un un scrutin à
main levé tout à l'heure dans dans les
musique nous on a pu être un peu surpris
on attendait plutôt un scrutin public
pour avoir pourquoi avoir choisi cette
option je n'ai pas choisi c'est la règle
lorsqu'un président doit soumettre par
exemple un projet de loi au vote et bien
s'il n'est pas saisi d'un scrutin public
il demande à l'assemblée de se prononcer
je n'avais pas de scrutin public j'ai
demandé aux sénateurs présents dans
l'hémicycle de se prononcer c'est
peut-être pas plus mal d'ailleurs de
voir que ce ce matin-là ce vendredi
matin-là ils étaient suffisamment
nombreux pour s'exprimer et voter sur ce
projet de loi merci pour cette
explication de de procédure Jean-Pierre
Michel l'a dit tout à l'heure l'histoire
est en marche l'évolution sociétale
continue est-ce que vous êtes de ceux
comme lui comme le rapporteur du texte
qui appelé très vite une loi sur la
famille avec notamment les dispositions
sur la PMA voir sur la GPA même si pour
l'instant le chef de l'État a dit qu'il
y était opposé écoutez je réponds sur la
première partie de votre question j'ai
entendu de la part de tous les
parlementaires y compris dans les rangs
de de l'opposition le souhait qu'il y
ait un vrai débat sur la famille donc
bien entendu que j'appelle de mon vœux
de mes vœux un débat à l'occasion d'un
texte sur sur la famille le contenu sera
déterminé et là je vous donnerai ma
position un petit peu plus tard merci
beaucoup Jean-Pierre bal d'être venu en
direct sur notre antenne pour réagir à
l'adoption par le Sénat de ce projet de
loi sur le mariage pour tous d'autres
sénateurs maintenant vont venir nous
rejoindre sur le plateau pour nous
donner un petit peu leur état d'esprit
pour ou contre Gérard longuer sénateur
UMP de laameuse voilà s'installe Gérard
Longuet qui pose de façon très dynamique
ses
dossiers à vous aussi je vais vous
demander votre réaction bien sûr après
l'adoption par le Sénat du du Tex ce
matin d'abord une déception c'est qu'il
n ait pas eu un scrutin public le
président le président vient me dire
qu'il n'a pas été saisi d'un scrtin il n
pas été saisi il e été il e été prudent
de sa part comme président du Sénat
d'interroger les présidents de groupe je
vous sent très remonter dans
l'opposition sur ce scrutin M levé tout
à l'heure dans l' totalement totalement
parce que le sentiment que l'on peut
retenir de cette précipitation pour
faire adopter ce texte à mainlever était
sans doute qu'il n'y avait pas l'unité
dans le camp de la gauche au sens large
ni même dans le camp de la droite oui
mais nous nous l'acceptions nous avons
donné la liberté de vote c'est un
principe sur des sujets de de conviction
intime de laisser la liberté de vote et
en effet certains collègues UMP se sont
abstenus certains ont voté pour
l'immense majorité a voter contre ce
texte pourquoi parce que les débats pour
deux raisons le la première c'est que
les débats ont apporté la
démonstration que cette orientation pose
beaucoup plus de questions qu'elle ne
règle de problème certes les homosexuels
pouront se marier c'est parfait mais
aucun des sujets liés à l'adoption
l'affiliation la PMA la GPA ne sont
traité à cet instant donc il y a un
affichage symbolique rien de réglé dans
la pratique mais vous vous avez écouté
comme nous à à la fin de la séance la
garde des sa Christian tobira qui s'est
porté garante des droits des enfants
dans notre pays oui enfin c'est c'est
pas tout à fait la vérité la vérité
c'est qu'il faut des dispositions
législatives voilà des gens qui peuvent
se marier et qui ne peuvent pas procréer
ils ne peuvent pas procréer s'ils
veulent sincèrement je peux imaginer
qu'ils sont sincères éduquer des enfants
il faudra bien qu'ils en trouvent et ils
ne ils sont obligés de faire appel à des
couples
hétérosexuels soit eux-mêmes être de
temps en temps hétérosexuel soit faire
appel à la science mais ils vont priver
par définition l'enfant à naître de sa
véritable filiation donc c'est un sujet
majeuroig le droit à l'origine en
particulier finalement si vous n'aviez
pas envie de voir la gauche porter cette
réforme pourquoi la droite qui a été au
pouvoir pendant un certain nombre
d'années n'a rien fait pour faire
évoluer par exemple le pack c'était dans
le programme de Nicolas Sarkozi en 2007
mais parce que nous ne sommes pas
parfaits parce que Nicolas Sarkozi n'a
gouverné que 5 ans et parce qu'il a en
2008 ce que ne fait pas le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui porter réponse aux
questions principales un point
d'ailleurs que dans les sondages les
Français disent aujourd'hui Sarco aurait
fait mieux que Hollande 55 45 c'est
cruel pour le président élu il y a à
peine 10 mois merci Gérard longu d'être
venu sur notre plateau on accueille
maintenant le président de la commission
des lois le sénateur socialiste
Jean-Pierre Sueur bonjour bonjour P
j'imagine que vous vous êtes dans un
état d'esprit totalement différent de
celui de Gérard longuer très satisfait
de ce vote positif de l'adoption du
projet de loi mariage pour tous au Sénat
ce matin oui je pense à toutes les
personnes
homosexuelles qui pendant des décennies
et des siècles même ont été vilipandé
montré du droit du Doig
injurier et qui pendant longtemps ont
vécu dans la honte et qui depuis un
certain nombre d'années revendique la
fierté la fierté d'être reconnu comme
étant ce qu'elles sont et aujourd'hui je
sais que pour elle c'est un grand jour
parce que ce texte sur le mariage c'est
une forme de reconnaissance et donc elle
l'attendait le texte est adopté
maintenant au Sénat il sera adopté très
rapidement je le pense à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui va adopter conforme le texte
tel qu'il sort du Sénat aujourd'hui
c'est le souhait de Jean-Pierre Michel
tel qu'il a exprimé sur notre ce matin
je peux pas préjuger mais je pense que
le texte déjà eu des contacts avec V de
l'É et qu'il y a eu des contacts et je
crois pouvoir dire que le texte qu'il
est tel qu'il a été voté par le sén très
précisément est susceptible d'être
adopté tel quel à l'Assemblée nationale
maintenant c'est au débuté dans juger ce
qui simplifierait la procédure éviterait
une deuxème lecture au Sénat et donc
permettrait l'adoption définitive du du
projet loi avant l'été et comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure en séance euh ce
n'est pas fini
parce que nous avons des sujets devant
nous on nous a constamment dit et je
crois que Gérard Longuet le disait à
l'instant que ce texte en fait n'était
pas un texte sur le mariage mais que il
impliquait d'autres textes il impliquait
la PMA la GPA et cetera j'ai toujours
dit non nous avons voté un texte sur le
mariage et sur l'adoption dans certaines
conditions mais Jean-Pierre Michel le
rapporteur du texte dit lui que
l'histoire est en marche que l'évolution
sociétale va continuer et que ces
dispositions notamment sur la PMA
devront être contenues dans la future
loi futur projet de loi autour de la
famille ou écoutez nous verrons euh je
je connais la position de Jean-Pierre
Michel à ce vous av moins moins vite que
lui non moi je dis simplement la chose
suivante nous avons voté un texte et ce
texte il est comme il est et moi je l'ai
voté comme il est il y a euh des sujets
comme la PMA en particulier et la GPA
qui suscite de pour moi beaucoup
d'interrogations je n'ai pas de par
exemple sur la GPA j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de doutes c'est beaucoup
d'interrogation sur la PMA je demande à
travailler donc il ne faut pas me faire
dire monsieur suur vous avez voté ce
texte donc vous allez en voter un autre
demain je verrai et nous sommes nombreux
à dire dans tous les groupes de ce Sénat
nous verront lorsqu'il y aura un texte
éventuel qui sera présenté mais il y a
un point sur lequel il y a un large
accord entre par exemple Jean-Pierre
Michel le rapporteur et Patrice gellard
qui s'est exprimé au nom de l'UMP et
cela est issu de toutes les auditions
auxquelles nous avons procédé c'est que
chacun voit bien qu'il faut reprendre
notre législation sur l'adoption qu'il
s'agisse de couple hétérosexuel ou
homosexuel il y a beaucoup à pourquo ne
pas l'avoir fait à ce moment-là
l'occasion de ce texte la droite parle
de précipitation elle peutêre raisonut
parce que parce que la question elle se
pose de toute façon et même s'il n'y
avait pas eu de texte sur le mariage
elle se serait posé nous devons
approfondir la question et j'attends
beaucoup pour ma part de la loi que
prépare madame
Bertinotti sur l'adoption vous comprz
prenez seulement l'adoption pliniiare il
devient absurde de dire à un enfant et
c'est encore plus absurde naturellement
par rapport à un couple
homosexuel que il n'a pas à connaître
ses origines donc la question du droit
aux origines à la connaissance des
origines elle se pose de manière
cruciale aujourd'hui donc là vous
rejoignez les les les propos de Gérard
longuer à l'instant sur notre et il peut
y avoir des convergences vous le savez
bien on l'a vu effectivement on l'a
entendu dans dans l'émiss sur certains
points effec peut plus tenir les
discours sur l'adoption que l'on tenait
il y a 30 ans ou 50 ans c'est c'est tout
à fait évident et les auditions les
nombreuses auditions auxquelles nous
avons procédé nous ont montré que ces
textes ont vieilli et qui ne
correspondent plus à la réalité donc
voilà nous avons du boulot devant nous
très bien merci beaucoup Jean-Pierre su
donc effectivement la réflexion continue
au sein de votre commission des Lois
Jean-Vincent placer le président du
groupe écologiste est sur notre plateau
à vous également j'ai demandé votre
réaction après l'adoption du du texte
par le Sénat une grande joie simplement
de d'avoir été présent pour ce beau
moment alors moi je n'aime pas tellement
galvoder les mot donc on dit toujours
d'un accord d'un texte qu' est
historique je crois pour le coup
celui-là il l' il a été voté après un
long débat extrêmement intéressant avec
des échanges tout à la fois techniques
et toute à la fois politiqu et toute à
la fois passionné et puis des moments
d'émotion aujourd'hui aussi pendant les
explications de vote on a entendu est
ban Bassa sur effectivement son parcours
personnel et les amis qu'el a on a aussi
entendu votre émotion tout à l'heure en
tant queenfant adopté tout à fait je
crois que c'est un texte qui bien sûr
est est global et général et qui
également interpelle les uns et les
autres selon leur parcours selon leur
relation par rapport à la famille par
rapport également au au au monde de de
l'homosexualité et c'est vrai que
l'intervention d'ester ben Bassa m'a m'a
beaucoup ému cela d'ailleurs m'a incité
à à à parler un petit peu du du mien de
bon je le dis maintenant c'est vrai que
c nit plus le temps ni du débat ni de la
polémique mais de nombreux propos
péromptoir sur l'adoption m'ont m'ont
interpellé pendant le le débat c'était
le le temps pour moi de de dire les
choses à cette explication de vote j'ai
TR comment vous généralement c'est ces
débats ici au Sénat sur le Tex c'était
des débat passionné qui allait un petit
peu au-delà des des clivages politiques
oui je me
je me réjouis qu'il y ait des
parlementaires de l'UMP et du centre je
pense à à madame joanau je pense à
Monsieur carouci ou d'autres qui sont
allés au-delà pas de la consigne de vote
ici nous sommes au Sénat nous sommes
attachés à à la liberté de vote de
chacun des parlementaires mais qui sont
aller au-delà de disons du sentiment
général leur famille politique et je
trouve ça bien d'ailleurs qu'on puisse
sur ce type de texte avoir une opinion
propre et ça tout à l'honneur de des
parlementaires que que je viens de
nommer votre groupe avait desposé des
amendements notamment sur la PMA he
porté par Esther ben Bassa qui allit un
peu plus loin que ce que souhaitait le
gouvernement vous souhaitez que sur ces
questions de procréation médicale
assisté on avance vite oui euh le
premier le Premier ministre a annoncé le
texte famille à un moment c'était avant
l'été bon ce sera peut-être à à
l'automne il a indiqué que il y aurait
bien sûr la saisine du comité national
d'éthique et que ensuite lui-même
souhaitait à l'instar d'ailleurs des
groupes socialiste et écologiste à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
inscrire la PMA dans le texte famille
qui concerne de façon plus générale
l'ensemble qu'on soit homosexuel ou
hétérosexuel l'ensemble des des familles
qui souhaitent à s'assister par la
procréation euh médical pour pouvoir
évidemment avoir un enfant quand la
difficulté euh notamment biologique ou
génétique est présente donc ce ce ce
sujet nous importe beaucoup il existe
vous le savez pour les couples
hétérosexuels nous souhaitonsê plutô à
la pointe dans ce combat-là hein euh qui
n'est pas for forcément partagé par tout
le monde notamment au sein du
gouvernement on connait aussi les
réticences du chef de l'État François
Hollande a toujours dit qu'il était
assez partagé hein sur ces questions
deé je crois s'est prononcé pour pendant
sa campagne électorale le premier min le
Premier ministre a dit qu'il étaiit
favorable les présidents des groupes
socialistes à l'Assemblée nationale et
je crois aussi au Sénat sont sont pour
les groupes vous êes confiant euh ben
écoutez euh maintenant la vie euh euh
fait que je fais de plus en plus
attention à à la devise à Cour des
comptes qui veut qui c'est vous le savez
la confiance n'exc pas le contrôle donc
j'ai toute à la fois confiance et toute
à la fois je vais contrôler pour
terminer Jean-Vincent Placé 8 jours de
débat ici au Sénat vous dites maintenant
c'est bon ça suffit pour les réformes de
société on passe au social à l'éc non je
je dis qu'il faut mener de de de front
l'ensemble des réformes qui devaient
être entreprises je pense au au non
cumule des mandats je pense au au projet
de loi qui va arriver sur la
transparence de la vie que et qui sera
un moment éalement ou mais sur la crise
sociale et économique que traverse le
pays il faut peut-être aussi avancer en
priorité sur ces dossiers non c'est pas
votre point de vue je vous l'ai dit je
pense qu'il faut aller de de paire l'un
n'exclut pas l'autre mais vous le savez
moi je suis porteur avec mes amis
écologistes d'une demande forte auprès
du président de la République de
changement de cap économique et social
avec moins d'austérité moins de rigueur
vers la nécessité de de la relance
économique par l'investissement
notamment l'investissement écologique
donc vous le voyez nous aurons de beaux
débats à venir dans les prochains mois
ici et et en dehors très bien ben
écoutez merci beaucoup Jean va semplacer
d'être venu comme d'autres avant vous
exprimer au nom de votre groupe après
l'adoption donc par le Sénat tout à
l'heure du projet de loi mariage pour
tous on va peut-être faire un dernier
aller-retour vers la tribune de presse
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat hmicyc doit
être bien vide maintenant Delphine pour
faire un dernier point avec vous sur ces
débats ces 8 jours de débat oui pine
effectivement l'émicycle s'est vidé
assez rapidement après la dernière prise
de parole de Christiane tobira alors
maintenant que va-t-il se passer et bien
pour ce projet de loi il va retourner à
l'Assemblée nationale pour une seconde
lecture effectivement les articles il
ont été votés conforme au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée ne seront pas discutés ce
qui va considérablement accélérer la
procédure législative le Sénat a fait
adopter une dizaine d'amendements de la
commission des lois alors en ce qui
concerne les principales modifications
du Sénat par rapport à la version issue
de l'Assemblée nationale il y a le
principe d'égal traitement entre les
époux les couples de même sexe et ceux
de sexe différents et bien qui est
consacré en tête du Code civil le Sénat
également adopté un amendement du
Gouvernement qui pourra maintenant
procéder par ordonnance aux
coordinations nécessaires justement pour
garantir la conformité avec la loi de
cet égal traitement entre couples de
même sexe et de sexes différents en ce
qui concerne la dévolution des noms de
famille le Sénat a rétabli la règle
traditionnelle qui veut que en cas et
bien de lorsqu'il n'y a pas en l'absence
de choix l'enfant adopté porte le nom de
son père et euh pour les enfants en cas
de désaccord et bien les enfants adoptés
porteront les deux noms par ordre
alphabétique il y a eu également des
amendements pour garantir pour interdire
les adoptions successives pour éviter
les pluries parentalités enfin des
mesures de simplification des règles de
célébration des mariages ont également
été votées par les sénateurs les
sénateurs a noté que les amendements de
la droite aussi bien de l'UMP et que de
l'Union centriste qui proposait une
union civile pour donc se substituer au
mariage pour les couples de même sexe et
bien ces amendements ont été repoussés
de même que les amendements écologistes
et communistes qui proposé d'autoriser
la PMA pour les couples de femmes et
bien ces amendements ont été retirés par
leurs auteurs il s'agissait d'amendement
d'appel et on a bien compris que ces
amendements et bien seront à nouveau
discutés lors du projet de loi sur la
famille alors on sait que Jean-Pierre
Michel a eu un coup de fil he du
rapporteur à l'Assemblée le socialiste
Erwan Binet le texte va donc retourner
très prochainement à l'Assemblée et
pourrait revenir au Sénat et bien aux
alentours du 23 24 mai si il y a un vote
conforme il n'y aura pas de commission
mixte paritaire et le vote du Sénat en
second lieu aura valeur de loi voilà
pine ce qu'on pouvait dire et bien sur
l'ensemble de ce projet de loi merci
beaucoup Delphine pour toutes vos
interventions dans dans la tribune de
presse et merci pour ce dernier papier
très précis aujourd'hui euh Chantal
joanau sénatrice UMP euh udi pardon oh
là là là gaffe udi est avec nous sur le
plateau bonjour euh vous faites partie
des des des quelques sénateurs de votre
groupe hein qui ont voté pour le projet
de loi donc j'imagine satisfaite
aujourd'hui satisfaite même si
maintenant le temps est à la
réconciliation et puis beaucoup de
questions ont été soulevées qui
demandent des réponses assez rapide sur
l'adoption pliniiaèire euh avec tous les
problèmes qu'elle pose puisqu'elle gomme
complètement en fait l'origine de de
l'enfant et et cette fiction de de
l'adoption pliniiare n'est n'est pas
bonne et à mon avis elle n'est pas bonne
ni pour les hétérosexuels ni pour les
homosexuel donc c'est une question qui
est commune et puis la question de la
procréation médicalement assistée demain
oui sur l'adoption c'est un point que
vient de soulever à l'instant sur notre
plateau Jean-Pierre s le président de la
commission des lois ici au Sénat et j'ai
l'impression que sa commission va
engager une grande réflexion autour de
de de ces questions d'adoption puisque
le texte n'a rien résolu et qu'il va
falloir mais Dominique bertinoti la
ministre de la Famille se dirige vers
notre plateau donc elle va peut-être
pouvoir nous donner plus de détails mais
effectivement du point de vue de
l'adoption rien n'est résolu oui non
mais c'est vraiment un sujet central ça
a certainement justifié beaucoup
d'opposition et et ce qui est très
dommage c'est qu'on a mis c'est qu'on a
discuté à l'envers il aurait fallu
commencer par avoir ce travail de fond
avant de parler du mariage pour tous et
ça aurait certainement apaisé énormément
d'opposition Dominique bertinoti la
ministre de la Famille va pouvoir vous
répondre dans quelques instants juste
Chantal joanau d'une façon globale
comment vous avez trouvé la tonalité des
débats ici au Sénat bah étant totalement
fan du Sénat vous le savez j'ai toujours
trouvé que la qualité des débats dans
l'hémicycle était à la hauteur de ce
débat et on a eu vraiment ça a été tout
à fait exemplaire de ce qu'on attend du
Sénat et de ce qu'on attend du travail
parlementaire il y a pas eu d'excès de
langage de de décor ou de volonté
théâtrale des uns et des autres donc
j'ai trouvé que le débat a été assez
assez éclairant même si les positions
parfois ont une coloration un peu
politique vous regrettez que dans
l'opposition il n'y ait pas eu plus de
voix pour soutenir à vos côté ce texte
il y en a eu
elles sont pas toujours exprimer au sein
de mon groupe
udi le président a souhaité que je
m'exprime et je le remercie parce que
c'est une bonne chose de montrer que sur
des questions de société il y a des
diversités de
position Parti socialiste aurait pu
aussi montrer un peu plus de diversité
de mesure dans ses propos très bien
merci beaucoup Chantal joanau Dominique
Bertinotti bonjour Merci d'être avec
nous on vous a entendu tout à l'heure
dans l'hémicycle on a entendu votre
bonheur votre
satisfaction maintenant c'est vrai tous
les interlocuteur qu'on vient d'avoir
sur le plateau l' l'ont souligné il
reste d'autres chantiers et notamment
sur l'adoption absolument mais c'est
aussi très intéressant et c'est à mettre
au crédit de de cette loi de voir que la
famille a tellement évolué que nombre de
questions qui touchent à la famille ont
été soulevés à l'occasion de cette loi
sur l'ouverture du du mariage et de
l'adoption couple de même sexe vous avez
parlé de l'adoption mais on pourrait
parler du statut du beauparent on
pourrait parler de la question de
l'accès à son histoire originelle pour
chaque enfant effectivement il y a bien
d'autres questions qui devront être
traitées par la suite mais à tel point
que certains parlementaires se demande
si on n pas fait les choses à l'envers
il aurait pas fallu commencer par
résoudre ces questionsl avant de finir
par statuer sur ce texte mais
paradoxalement je pense que non je pense
que s'il n'y avait pas eu cette loi
cette loi a servi de coup de projecteur
sur sur les familles et c'est parce que
ça peut-être parce que c'est c'était un
des éléments les les les plus forts que
d'ouvrir le mariage et l'adoption couple
de même sexe que ça a provoqué tout le
débat en chaîne ensuite sur d'autres
questions je ne suis pas sûre qu'en
procédant à l'inverse on est pu arriver
à ce à quoi nous allons arriver et
aujourd'hui et dans les mois qui
viennent ça va faire partie des
prochains projets sur lesquels votre
ministère va travailler absolument et a
déjà commencé à travailler d'accord pour
un texte avec quel calendrier à peu près
qui sera plutôt fin de l'année 2013 vous
l'avez sans doute entendu tout à l'heure
dans l'mique le rapporteur du texte ici
au scénat Jean-Pierre Michel a dit
l'histoire est en marche l'évolution
sociétal doit continuer vite il appelle
de ses vœux également ce grand Tex sur
la famille qui qui est annoncé avec
notamment les mesures autour de de la
PMA vous espérez le voir vous espérez
que ce texte va voir le jour quand à peu
près écoutez c'est ce que je viens de
vous dire l'ensemble du texte sera
certainement prêt pour la fin de l'année
2013 mais vous savez bien que sur la
question de la procréation médicalement
assistée nous attendrons l'avis du
comité consultatif d'éthique et nous
verrons bien à ce moment-là ce que nous
nous ferons les débats seront plus
tendus on sent qu'il y a plus de plus de
réticence dans votre majorité sur ces
questionsl non mais il est normal que
sur des questions d'éthique vous savez
sans même pas parler de procréation
médicalement assistée certains réclament
la levée de l'anonymat de l'accouchement
sous X bon c'est des questions qui sont
des questions suffisamment fortes pour
qu'elles nécessitent du temps de la
réflexion de la consultation et nous
allons prendre ce temps cette réflexion
et cette consultation merci beaucoup
Dominique bertinoti d'être venu une
dernière fois en direct sur notre
plateau on va finir cette émission avec
Esther Benbassa très représentative hein
de tout le combat mené en faveur du
mariage homosexuel c'est un combat que
vous portez depuis très longtemps vous
l'avez encore rappelé tout à l'heure
dans l'émicycle est B Bassa oui c'est un
combat que je mène depuis longtemps
parce que aussi j'ai j'ai eu des
épisodes dans mon histoire qui qui m'ont
poussé à à m'engager davantage en
pensant à ceux qui vivaient ça au jour
le jour et pas dans les meilleures
conditions c'est ce que vous avez
expliqué pendant les explications de de
vote tout à l'heure vous avez raconté un
peu des des histoires personnel que que
vous av traversé quelle a été votre
émotion quand le texte a été adopté et
tout d'abord
j'ai je j'étais un peu comme ça vous
voyez je n'avais plus de sentiment rien
je je regardais et puis l'émotion est
remonté et j'étais tellement contente
j'ai regardé dans les dans les loges
là-haut tous ces jeunes qui étaient venu
nous soutenir et j'étais contente pour
eux j'étais contente pour ce que je ne
connais pas
j'étais contente pour tous ceux qui
continuent à souffrir parce que ils ont
des enfants ils savent
pas comment les si vous voulez faire de
leurs enfants euh quelque enfin quelque
chose comme comme les autres enfants il
faut banalyser ça il faut plus qu'on
parle voilà lui il a un papa et une
maman et lui il a deux mamans elle a
deux papas et un peu aller au-delà de
tout cela même si beaucoup de questions
se posent aujourd'hui sur le droit aux
origines he sur l'affiliation mais je
suis d'accord avec vous mais on ne peut
pas tout régler en même temps il faut
euh il faut doucement prendre les choses
là la loi est votée elle va aller à
l'Assemblée ensuite madame Bertinotti
nous a nous a promis une loi sur la
famille elle vienten parler
effectivement oui ensuite on verra bien
sûr qu'il y aura des problèmes quand on
change les choses quand on sort de son
conservatisme devant la nouveauté il y a
tout toujours des problèmes il y aura
des problèmes de transcription sur
l'état civil il y aura des problèmes
avec le livret de famille il y aura des
rejet il y aura encore de l'homophobie
oui c'est pas le miracle qu'on attend
mais on attend qu'un gouvernement de
gauche aide à changer les choses je sais
qu'il y a le chômage je sais qu'il y a
la crise économique mais bon on ne peut
pas tour serz vigilante pour que ces
grandes lois sur la famille voient le
jour pendant le quinqu de François
Hollande ah oui oui je vais pas lâcher
madame Bertinotti mais ça fait un moment
me connaît maintenant Esther B bassin on
va revoir sur notre antenne le vote du
Sénat sur l'ensemble du projet de loi on
regarde à nouveau ce moment en séance un
scrutin à main levée dans l'émissycle
tout à
l'heure mes chers collègues je mets au
voix l'ensemble du projet de loi ouvrant
le mariage au couple de personnes de
même sexe ceux qui sont favorables pour
l'adopter lève la
main
merci ceux qui sont
contre merci
abstention mes chers collègues le Sénat
a adopté le projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage au couple de personnes de même
sexe voilà c'était en séance il y a je
sais plus une demi-heure 3 qu heur de ça
donc l'adoption par le Sénat de ce
projet loi mariage pour tous par un
scrutin à main levée qui a énervé
beaucoup de sénateurs de l'opposition
mais le président Bell est venu s'en
expliquer sur notre plateau il nous a
dit qu'il n'avait pas été saisi d'un
scrutin public et puis de toute façon
chaque groupe politique du Sénat a
annoncé qu'il publierait dans le
compte-rendu la liste des sénateurs qui
ont voté pour et qui ont voté contre
merci Esther Benbassa d'avoir terminé
cette émission avec nous en direct sur
Public Sénat merci bien sûr à toutes les
équipes de la rédaction de Public Sénat
qui nous ont accompagné pendant ces 8
jours de Direct Matin après-midi soir
donc beaucoup d'heures de diffusion
autour de ces débats dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat merci à tous d'avoir été fidèles à
ces rendez-vous et de nous avoir suivi
sur notre antenne et à très bientôt pour
de nouvelles émissions sur la
séance